[Musique]
Albert Dupontel, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Bah
acteur, réalisateur, vieillissant,
professionnellement toléré et
biologiquement en surcis. Voilà.
On vous reçoit aujourd'hui parce que on
est d'ailleurs on est très content de
vous recevoir. On est on est on a vu
votre film Adieu les cons et on voudrait
creuser en fait votre perception et
votre capacité à analyser notre société
parce que j'ai j'ai un copain
réalisateur de cinéma qui m'a toujours
dit que le cinéma l'art les artistes
c'est les saltins banan c'est eux qui
piquent le peuple et qui réveille le la
leur perception sur la la réalité.
Comment vous percevez le le 21e siècle
avec le Covid, les problèmes de
géopolitique, les problèmes d'énergie,
les problèmes de de politique qui nous
qui nous gouvernent ?
En fait, moi je m'intéresse au bout de
la chaîne à savoir le le drame humain
qui résulte de tout ce que vous avez
raconté. Euh voilà, si on prend les
grands classiques de la littérature
française, Hugo n'a n'a rien fait
d'autre que de raconter les
le carnage qui était fait en cours au
siècle que lui a traversé. Donc moi ce
qui m'intéresse, c'est les petits gens.
Voilà. Qu'est-ce qui résulte de toute
cette géopolitique délirante que vous
évoquez souvent brillément d'ailleurs
avec des intervenants plus qualifiés que
moi ? Donc voilà, moi ces petits gens ça
m'intéresse. Donc je à partir de là, je
crée des personnages qui apparemment
sont souvent des déviants. Alors à
l'époque de Bernie, ils étaient
délibérément déviants. J'avais créé ce
personnage là qui était pratique.
C'était un clown. Euh là dans les Kong,
vous avez cité, c'est surtout des
personnages qui sont euh totalement
intégrés et à un moment donné anecdote
sociale fait divers de leur vie, il se
retrouve en marge de ce que vous appelez
la transhumance sociale, le troupeau
social. C'est
Oui. Oui. Non mais c'est vrai, c'est
c'est voilà, on est on est tous dans une
le on est tous éduqués pour participer à
un troupeau lequel troupeau
effectivement finit par être suicidaire
dans dans son délire d'avidité, de
frénésie. Donc d'un coup ces personnages
vont se retrouver un petit peu sur la
marge. Ils sont pas marginaux mais vont
se retrouver sur la marge et la grande
aventure intérieure commence. qui vont
se rencontrer eux-mêmes déjà qui est le
truc que les dominants n'aiment pas
qu'on fasse. C'est pour ça que l'école
souvent nous éduque pour participer à
une collectivité mais pas à comprendre
les émotions intérieures et puis après
ils ont tellement de rencontres avec
eux-mêmes qu'ils vont se rencontrer déjà
physiquement, s'écouter, se regarder et
pourquoi pas s'aimer. Et là l'aventure,
en tout cas l'aventure de ces gens
m'intéresse. Donc ce que je vous raconte
là à travers une petite métaphore à
faire un petit film comme à du con, je
pense que c'est c'est il y a des
millions d'exemplaires dans le monde qui
résultent de de toutes les déviances
égomaniaques des élites qui nous
dirigent. Voilà ma perception, mais je
pourrais pas l'analyser en profondeur
comme vous le faites. Moi ce qui
m'intéresse encore une fois, c'est le
genre humain. Voilà, je crois beaucoup à
l'individu.
C'est quoi les dominant pour vous ?
C'est quoi les les élites ? C'est c'est
bah les élites, ils se définissent
eux-mêmes comme ça. Donc euh
il y a trois types d'élites. Il y a les
les les religieux, les politiques et les
marchands. Voilà. Donc dans l'histoire
de l'humanité, c'est ces gens-là qui
sont plus ou moins partagés le pouvoir.
Le doute de vivre a été a été comment
dire capté par les religieux qui vous
expliquent la mort c'est bien aussi et
qui vous donne des manuels, des modes
d'emploi, la Torah, le Coran, la Bible,
le Nouveau Testament et les marchands
qui aujourd'hui sont archi dominants,
qui n'ont d'autres buts que vous
transformer en consommateur. C'est
pratique, on pense à rien. Surtout ne
pensez pas trop, consommer, consommer.
Ils vont même des fois dans leur dans
leur dans leur calcul algorithmique à à
empêcher des gens de consommer, c'est
les gilets jaunes et qui se révèlent
d'ailleurs tout d'un coup citoyens.
C'est très intéressant le début des
gilets jaunes. C'est un truc intéressant
parce que ce sont des gens qui au début
protestent en tant que consommateur et
très vite derrière ça, il y a une
conscience citoyenne qui arrive qui
débouge plus ou moins directement sur la
la convention citoyenne qui qui a
proposé vraiment des choses
intéressantes. Donc voilà, c'est
intéressant que derrière le troupeau
qu'on essaie de faire, tout d'un coup
l'individu se révèle et puis après bah
il y a les politiques. Moi c'est ceux
que j'ai connu très dominant quand
j'étais plus jeune, c'était les grands
éganiaques politiques qui avent au
pouvoir et qui qui expliquent la vie.
Voilà, derrière ça, il y a des individus
très particuliers que vous connaissez
mieux que moi. Voilà.
Est-ce que vous avez essayé de vous
mettre dans les chaussures d'un
politique ? Est-ce que vous avez essayé
de vous mettre dans leur propre conduite
introspective,
de voir comment ils appliquaient le la
résilience pour pouvoir gouverner ?
Est-ce que vous avez essayé de de
Alors, c'est intéressant ce que vous
dites parce que ça va être l'objet d'un
approch normalement s'il approche un
film et c'est d'ailleurs comme ça que je
vous ai rencontré via internet. Voilà,
je cherchais des informations que j'ai
eu.
Connaissez la chaîne un peu ? Oui oui,
je connaissais la chaîne justement dans
le cadre de recherche d'un prochain film
qui devrait s'appeler Second Tour. Je
veux absolument savoir le profil et
comprendre un peu ce que vous appelez la
géopolitique. Et alors humainement, je
crois percevoir euh les égotistes
furieux qui nous gouvernent parce que
pour dire voter pour moi, il faut quand
même être un peu fou. Et alors il y a il
y a des grandes figures au 20e siècle,
si on prend Clémenceau, de Gaule, voilà,
c'est des gens convaincus, sincères,
mégalomaniaques, un peu fou certainement
mais qui sont arrivés au bon moment, au
bon endroit. Les autres, c'est des
grands narcissistes qui qui se partagent
le pouvoir tel que moi j'ai pu le vivre
dans ma jeunesse. Euh la première fois
que j'ai eu le droit de voter, c'était
Chirak Mitran. Bah c'était deux grands
narcissistes qui s'affrontaient et
souvent c'est des gens qui sont très
forts en rhtorique de plateau, qui sont
très forts en communication. En terme
d'action, c'est plus compliqué. Voilà.
Et puis j'ai été éduqué par un papa qui
me disait bahà il y en avait un qui
était premier ministre quand j'étais à
l'école primaire, c'était Chirac et puis
l'autre qui était ministre de
l'intérieur et ou de la justice comme
mon père est en Algérie donc il m'a
présenté le personnage.
Donc c'est des gens qui me font peur en
fait à vrai dire. Alors après, me mettre
dans la peau, ça va être compliqué parce
que j'ai j'ai un regard beaucoup plus
moins égomaniaque, moins moins moins
mégolomaniaque, beaucoup plus humble,
beaucoup plus anxieux mais ça reste des
créatures fascinantes. Ça reste des
créatures fascinantes. C'est pour ça
j'aimerais en parler. Alors derrière ces
gens-là, c'est évident, je suis en train
de dire une biographie de Chorchild qui
est assez passionnante. Derrière ces
gens-là, il y a un truc qui amène à
l'enfance. Il y a toujours des carences
affectives ou pédagogiques. Euh si on
prend le cas du gars qui gouverne en ce
moment,
euh c'est pas forcément un gars méchant
qui se réunit avec ses copains pour dire
comment on va on va [__] les Français.
Mais je pense qu'il y a une carence
pédagogique. Ce qu'ils appellent l'élite
c'est un circuit qui finalement évite
les émotions populaires. Et c'est
intéressant. Voilà quelqu'un qui qui a
fait une grande école qui est passé dans
une banque à l'économie puis après au
gouvernement. En tant que scénariste,
moi je dis euh il manque une case, il il
manque la case populaire parce que les
émotions populaires sont irrationnelles
et les personnes que j'ai évoqué comme
Clémenceau de Gaulle ont été confronté à
des émotions populaires très fortes qui
les mettaient plus à même de comprendre
le peuple euh ce que les gens qui
gouvernent totalement mais il y a pas
que lui. Les gens avant aussi n'étaient
pas vraiment n'ont pas vraiment eu cette
sensibilitélà. Donc voilà. Alors
qu'est-ce qui est quel est quel est
l'aveuglement intérieur qui fait que ces
gens-là arrivent au pouvoir et tout et
tout ? Ça, c'est un truc qui est assez
fascinant. Il faut beaucoup de culot
pour dire voter pour moi. Il faut
beaucoup d'apomb pour dire une chose et
son contraire à quelque chose
d'intervalle. Il faut beaucoup de de de
oui de de narcisse d'amour de soi pour
évoluer aussi librement dans la dans la
lumière avec semble-t-il une perception
des choses qui est très éloignée et ça
c'est assez fascinant comme comme
archétype psychosocial. Voilà mais je
suis à mes débuts de de la découverte.
De toute façon, dans le film que
j'ambitionne de faire, je ne parlerai
pas de cette forme extérieure. Ce qui
m'intéresse, c'est la forme intérieure.
Et je m'intéresse notamment à un
personnage dont on peut voir euh la vie
euh vraiment fascinant, c'est Robert
Kennedy. On peut voir un documentaire
sur Netflix en ce moment. Alors, je vous
recommande pas de voir Nflix, ça c'est
très énergivore, mais malgré tout, c'est
là où j'ai trouvé ce ce documentaire et
et le personnage, il a un parcours il
est mis en place par son père, un
oligarque pas pas très clair qui était
plus ou moins qu'africoté avec la mafia
à l'époque de la prohibition dont
Churchill d'ailleurs a sollicité le
renvoi en tant qu'ambassadeur des
États-Unis en Angleterre parce qu'il
était trou les nazis plutôt sympathique.
Donc voilà, un personnage très ambigu,
il sort de ce système là, c'est un type
brillant qui s'intéresse à l'intérêt
général mais qui commence comme
assistant dey et donc il commence avec
un un préjugé très fort par rapport au
monde dans lequel il arrive. Des
convictions. Et ce qui est intéressant,
c'est qu'en 10 ans, les convictions
explosent,
disparaissent. Et on a un autre individu
qui surgit notamment l'acmé de cette
transformation, c'est quand il est en
campagne électorale et qu'il annonce à
Indianapolis dans un dans un ghetto
black la mort de Martin Lutherking
debout sur un pickup forcément
improvisé. On le voit dans le
documentaire, il a ce réflexe toujours
intéressant de de repousser sa mèche. Il
dit "Est-ce qu'ils sont au courant ?" On
lui dit "Non." Donc il va annoncer dans
un des droits les plus les plus comment
dire, les plus tumultueux, les plus à
vif par rapport à ça à une communauté.
La mort d'un de ses leaders un des
leaders charismatiques don dans
l'histoire se rappelle encore du nom. Et
il faut écouter les mots de ce
personnage, faut écouter sa conviction,
faut écouter la puissance d'une parole
quand elle vient de quelqu'un aussi
éveillé, aussi sincère, il y a pas de
discours, il improvise, il récite de
mémoire un poème d'échile. Bref, c'est
totalement bouleversant. Voilà, un héros
des temps modernes et qui traduit sa
conviction et quelque part alors c'est
ce que je l'imagine mais peut-être que
c'est une vision manikenne ou
complotiste peut-être je ne l'exclus pas
mais quelque part les dominants les
vrais dominants pas pas ceux qui
gouvernent officiellement ce qu'on
appelle les néoconservateurs, les lobby
militaires industriels dont Zin
d'ailleurs disait qu'il fallait se
méfier quand il a passé le pouvoir à
Kennedy. Ces gens-là prennent conscience
du danger parce que le MC est convaincu.
Il est convaincu et il convainc les gens
et un mois après, je crois qu'il est
assassiné. Et Romain Gar lui dit
d'ailleurs 15 jours avant vous savez
qu'ils vont vous tuer. Kennedy dit oui,
je le sais. Donc il y a dans ce
personnage, voilà, alors je sors ce
personnage comme une dystopie. C'est pas
du tout le commun des mortels des
politiques dont vous parlez, mais voilà,
quelqu'un qui est convaincu, qui va vers
un destin qu'il imagine tragique mais
qui est porteur d'un espoir phénoménal.
Cet espoir, cette parole là, elle peut
ressurgir tôt ou tard. C'est ce que je
m'efforcé de raconter dans un film
forcément avec des avec des gens qui
vont l'empêcher, mais c'est pas la
monnaie courante de la politique telle
que moi je l'ai connu et telle que la
génération qui est la vôtre découvre en
ce moment les gens au pouvoir
indiscutablement. Voilà. D'où l'intérêt
de ce personnage. Ouis. Excusez-moi
cette parenthèse sur Kennedy. Pas de
problème. On vous conseille un bouquin
ou des bouquins sur euh la biographie de
Hoover.
Oui, bien sûr. Ou
Edgar Hoover, c'est c'est riche en
enseignement.
Il y a le bouquin de Duger, la
malédiction d'Edgar qui est vachement
intéressante aussi. Ouais,
c'est exactement celui-ci.
Ouis, mais je connais bien Marc Duger
moi qui m'en a parlé longuement. Il y a
plein de choses à raconter de lui. Celui
est magnifique. Elle elle on va vous
enchaîner sur une autre question.
La société de surveillance qu'on qu'on
voit à l'heure actuelle, vous la
percevez comment vous ?
Bah c'est c'est très
comment vous dire ça ? C'est très voilà,
vous parlez d'adio lescon. Adieu les con
c'est c'est quoi le message d'adolé les
con ? J'aime pas dire ça mais c'est la
difficulté de s'aimer dans un monde
répressif et anxiogène et la
surveillance technologique dont vous
êtes quelque part et vous maîtrisez
infiniment mieux que moi et ben voilà
c'est extrêmement anxiogène. Il y a pas
longtemps je fais une pétanque avec des
copains. On a le portable avec nous mais
qui est pas allumé et le lendemain sur
YouTube j'ai des pubs pour la pétanque.
Voilà qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? Alors ils
écoutent ça me paraît très bizarre donc
je pense pas qu'il y a des mecs avec des
casques mais il y a des algorithmes qui
relèvent des mots des expressions et qui
nous orient vers une possibilité de
consommation. Donc c'est un c'est une
écoute. Oui, c'est extrêmement
anxiogène. Euh c'est c'est comment dire
? C'est c'est indécent, c'est obsè. Je
me sens pas l'aise par rapport à ça. Le
problème c'est j'arrive pas à m'en
passer. Les bouquins dont je vous parle,
les DVD dont je vous parle, souvent je
les trouve sur Amazon. C'est pas bien de
passer par Amazon. Mais qu'est-ce que
c'est pratique. Alors pourquoi il y a
pas des plateformes européennes qui
pourraient faire aussi bien ? Je ne
comprends pas, ça me dépasse
complètement. Mais je trouve des DVD ou
des bouquins que je ne trouve nulle part
ailleurs. En deux clics, je les trouve
sur Amazon. Vous voyez l'ambiguïté du
système. Donc ce soit anxiogène à la
fois anxiogène et est utile, c'est
compliqué pour nous. Mais tout ce qui se
passe en ce moment, c'est un problème
qu'on doit régler avec nous-même. On est
en guerre contre nous-même avec le
Covid. Il faut qu'on change nos
comportements. C'est ce qu'il y a de
plus dur. On n même pas d'ennemis
désignés. Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ?
Alors,
bah qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire déjà ? Faut
faut Vous parlez tout à l'heure de la
culture, mais c'est très intéressant. La
culture, c'est l'identité d'un individu.
Euh effectivement, des artistes sont
venus et des grands artistes, hein, je
parle pas de moi, ça va de soi, mais qui
ont montré plutôt que la leadur, la
beauté du monde. Les marchands nous
montrent la leader du monde et nous
transforment quelque part en
consommateur. Ce qui est ce qu'on a de
plus né dans notre dans notre notre
comportement social. Alors que oui, la
culture, les les beaux films, les grands
bouquins, les Hugo, les Flobert, les
Balzac, le cinéma français de la grande
époque, des années 30, les musées, le
Louvre, le plafond de la chapelle 16, il
y a des gens qui ont qui ont été là,
Mozart, Bac, Betov, que sais-je, il y a
des gens qui ont été là pour dire on
n'est pas que ça, on n'est pas ce petit
animal qui cherche qu'à boire, à manger,
copuler, on est plus que ça. Vous
écoutez certains morceaux de musique. Je
suis pas féru, je suis pas mélomane,
mais il y a des morceaux de Mozart, par
exemple, je me dis il y a forcément
autre chose que ce que je suis. Il y a
quelque chose que je ne peux pas capter,
que je peux pas voir mais il y a
forcément autre chose parce que voilà,
il y a tout d'un coup il y a un médium,
c'est Mozart. Et pareil quand je dis
Hugo, pareil quand je lis des tas choses
même plus récentes, plus contemporaine.
Les films, j'en parle même pas. les
voyages que j'ai fait en tant queenfant
ou adolescent perdu dans un monde que je
ne comprenais pas et que je comprends
toujours pas, j'ai parfois eu des
entrevues de lucidité grâce à certains
films. Donc voilà, la solution, bah
l'éducation est une est une énorme
solution, énorme. Aujourd'hui, vous
éduquez les gamins différemment de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui. L'éducation
classique, l'éducation dans la
compétition, l'éducation dans la
rivalité, l'éducation bah traditionnelle
que j'ai connu qui était encore pire les
années 70, je sais pas s'ils ont fait
des progrès. Le fait de noter les
gamins, c'est une erreur de noter. Tout
le monde note tout le monde aujourd'hui.
Les profs sont notés, ils notent les
gamins, on note le taxi, on note
l'hôtel, on vous note vous. Enfin, c'est
quatèement con. Et donc on réduit
l'échelle de valeur. Donc une éducation
alternative,
réfléchie, censée, qui remet l'individu
face à lui-même, qui lui apprend comment
dire toutes ses émotions intérieures.
Bah, dans 20 ans, vous avez une
génération qui est différente, qui est
pour qui l'écologie est absolument
centrale, qui est altruiste, qui est
humaniste. J'ai vu moi quelques écoles
de ce type là en France, notamment une
dans la Drome et je trouvais ça
absolument passionnant de voir
qu'effectivement l'enfant est un génie.
il sait marcher tout seul, il sait
parler tout seul et puis on le met à
l'école et puis il devient un crétin
quelque part et donc il y a un truc qui
va pas dans le système. Alors ce que je
vous dis là, des tas de gens ont dit des
grands pédagogues. Je vous renvoie à
Montessori à Frainer, il y a un bouquin
qui s'appelle il y a un DVD avec Bernard
Blier qui s'appelle l'école buonière de
Jean-Paul Chanois 1948 qui raconte
Freinait dans un petit village provençal
et comment il s'en prend la pédagogie
classique et il change les choses. C'est
très très intéressant. Il y a des
grandes tragédies. Francisco Ferrer, un
pédagogue espagnol qui était fusillé par
les jésuites parce qu'il avait osé
changer le mode pédagogique de l'époque
et il avait des résultats foudroyants.
Donc les jésuites qui tenaient ça
vraiment dans une main fermée, bah ont
inventé qu'il était l'auteur d'un
attentat à Barcelone, ils l'ont fusillé
au début du du 20e siècle. Voilà. Voilà,
c'est pour vous dire quelle solution bah
la culture et la culture la meilleure
façon de l'aborder, c'est l'école et une
pédagogie moins moins moins compétitrice
et qui fait plus appel à l'intelligence
de l'enfant. Voilà, si je peux me
permettre
sur la société de surveillance, on y
revient.
Euh est-ce que vous avez adapté votre
vie pour essayer de passer entre les
gouttes ou passer à travers les mailles
du filet ? Est-ce que vous avez arrêté
de discuter de certaines choses au
téléphone ? Est-ce que vous avez arrêté
de de discuter devant votre ordinateur,
devant votre téléconnecté ?
Non non non, je je suis hyper bénin
comme mec. Donc je considère, je me sais
surveiller mais il y a pas grand chose à
voir.
Savez-vous surveiller ?
Bah je sais parce que je j'écoute des
gens comme vous parce que j'ai des
bouquins, j'en ai lu un paquet sur le
numérique et tout. l'épisode que je vous
raconter l'anecdote sur le fait de jouer
à la pétanque et le lendemain comme par
hasard des pubs sur la pétanque, mon
gamin qui fait des études très chouettes
en Angleterre me dit pareil quand ils
ont discussion avec des copains
ordinateurs fermés comme par hasard le
lendemain ils ont des pubs qui parlent
de ça donc oui on est écouté on est
surveillé comme vous peut-être pas mais
moi j'ai vraiment pas grandchose à
cacher et et donc quelque part je vis
avec ça si j'avais des choses à cach je
prendrai les précautions. Voilà, j'ai un
VPN. Donc quand je vais aller sur le
net, je prends le VPN.
Lequel ?
Euh IP Vanich, ça vous dit quelque chose
? Voilà, c'est celui qu'on m'a
conseillé. Peut-être que conseillera un
autre. J'ai un command informaticien qui
me tient au courant des risques que je
prends. Donc je suis conscience de ça.
Mais mais encore une fois, j'ai pas
grandchose à cacher. C'est c'est bien
bénin ce que j'envoie comme SMS ou comme
mail. Vraiment très très bénin. Donc
quelque chose à cacher ?
Peut-être mais voilà apprenez-le moi
mais vous dire voilà je passe par IP van
mais c'est plus par principe citoyen
dire j'ai pas envie qu'on sache que
j'aille voir il y a pas grandchose je
vais pas voir grand chose de méchant
mais voilà j'ai pas envie qu'on sache
alors je même quand je vous consulte
vous quand je vais voir sur YouTube et
cetera, par principe je prends ce petit
VPN qui marche pas toujours. Il y a des
documentaires d'Arté que j'essaie
d'avoir et quand je pars sur le VPN, je
peux pas les avoir parce qu'on me dit
vous êtes pas dans le bon pays. Alors je
cherche le bon pays où je peux avoir
voilà faut vous dire dans Adieu les
cons, il y a un informaticien qui pète
un câble et il y a toute une mise en en
image de ses capacités techniques pour
pouvoir aider un autre personnage du
film. Vous avez consulté des hackers ?
Vous avez consulté des gens du du
domaine ? Vous avez consulté ?
Ouais, j'ai consulté deux hackurs qui
courageusement n'ont pas voulu mettre
leur nom générique.
Euh, c'est par des journalistes qui
m'ont quand j'ai raconté l'histoire
m'ont dit "Bah nous, on a on a un gars
très fort dans la région, je dirais pas
laquelle." Il avait fait des
performances assez poustoufflantes de de
passer des films porno sur les écrans
publicitaires d'une gare pour prouver la
défaillance du système. Donc, il a des
petits soucis avec la justice. Bref,
j'ai rencontré, c'est un type adorable
et tout qui était assez proche
psychologiquement du profil que j'ai
définis dans le film. D'ailleurs, il
s'est senti très concerné par le
personnage, même s'il est plus jeune. Et
donc en gros, il m'a dit "Bah voilà,
tout ce que tu racontes, c'est possible
mais tu vas des fois un peu vite." Et
c'est lui par contre qui a construit les
interface qui a dit "Voilà, donc je
travaille avec des VFX beaucoup dans ce
film et il y a ils ont construit des
interfaces virtuelles et voilà ce qui se
passerait si tu la sécurité incendie."
Il m'a dit "Là tu vas un peu vite parce
qu'en pratique c'est plus compliqué. Les
ascenseurs voilà ce qui apparaît, la
domotique et cetera." Il m'a pris tout
ce langage là. Ils ont guidé les VFX sur
les interfaces des ordinateurs. Moi,
objectivement, j'y connais pas
grand-chose.
Comment il il est venu ce personnage à
germer dans votre tête ?
Juste c'est un personnage qui est
objectivement est confiné
intérieurement. Tout ça c'est écrit il a
2 ans et demi quand même. Et donc voilà,
je je me dis il y a un personnage qui
voudrait vivre mais qui peut plus. Il y
a un personnage qui qui veut vivre qui
peut vivre mais qui ne veut plus. Alors
je prends le cas du burnout. Et alors
dans l'idée que j'avais encore une fois
l'idée de que on a vraiment du mal à
s'aimer par les temps qui court, l'idée
que j'avais c'était que le personnage se
retrouvait dans une vraie compétition,
dans une vraie comment dire
compétitivité très fort informatiquement
mais avec un vrai problème par rapport
au fait de dire "Je t'aime." Voilà, je
t'aime c'est la base dans une existence
c'est dur à dire mais c'est ce qu'il
faut dire. Il faut bien trouver les
moments, les mots choisis, les personnes
avec qui le dire. Et ben lui, il a il a
complètement évité ce moment-là et s'est
consacré à son travail. Il est très
compétitif, il est très fort, ça a un
pur à cœur même s'il bosse pour
l'administration mais ça donc voilà, je
cherchais l'archétype du confinement par
rapport à quelqu'un qui avait une grande
histoire d'amour mais que sociétalement,
on avait dit c'est le personnage de
Virginie, sociétalement on lui dit "Bah
non, faut pas aimer, c'est pas le
moment, tu es trop jeune, tu as 15 ans,
le bébé on va s'en occuper, fais ta
vie." Alors elle a tellement fait sa vie
qu'elle finit par en crever parce
qu'elle respire des cochonneries. Donc
je je me sur un monde que je traverse.
Je le commente à ma façon un peu
maladroitement mais ce personnage là,
oui, c'est le geek. Et là, je connais
des geeks, un titre personnel qui sont
qui étaient pas ceux contrariés sur le
film, mais j'ai vraiment vu le
confinement intérieur et puis moi-même,
il y a beaucoup chez moi d'inhibition
par rapport à ça. J'en ai eu beaucoup
quand j'étais quand j'étais plus jeune.
Donc, j'ai pas été inventé bien loin.
Qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui permet de se
réfugier d'un monde réel qu'on ne
comprend pas ? Bah, c'est le virtuel. Et
dans ce virtuel, on est très compétitif
par rapport à la réalité que que vous
fréquentez tous les jours sur sur vos
réseaux. Voilà. Donc, il est né comme ça
ce personnage là, très fort socialement
mais perdu affectivement. Ils sont
souvent comme ça mes personnages.
Comment vous l'avez vécu le confinement
vous ?
Oh ben j'étais, j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance. Voilà, je je suis un antiin
grâce aux gens qui vous regardent, je
suis un anti et donc j'étais dans une
planque dans les sennes en pleine forêt
voilà tranquille et puis alors j'ai pas
mal vu de film énormément j'en déjà pas
mal j'ai encore vu encore plus et puis
puis j'ai réfléchi et je trouve que le
le confinement nous permet de nous
confronter à nous-même. Le la guerre qui
se déroule en ce moment encore une fois
c'est une guerre face à nous-même quoi.
C'est c'est la plus dure. Il faut qu'on
change notre mode de vie, il faut qu'on
change notre réflexion. Alors à mon âge
c'est encore c'est difficile. Les
gamins, c'est possible. d'où l'intérêt
d'une éducation peut-être différente,
même tellement différente.
Comment vous jugez l'action du
gouvernement sur le Covid ?
Bah encore une fois, c'est pas des
méchants qui se réunissent la nuit pour
dire on va on va on va se moquer du du
peuple que c'est ce je pense c'est des
gens qui sont pas formés pour ça. Et
pourtant moi à mon âge ça fait 30 ou 40
ans et même quand j'étais en médecine,
j'entendais parler de réchauffement
climatique et d'épidémie. Donc c'est
bizarre parce que moi j'étais au courant
en étant pas aussi pointu apparemment
que ces gens-là.
Et donc ils sont pas formés pour ça. Ce
qui m'étonne c'est l'apond qu'ils ont à
dire une chose et son contraire en
quelques jours. D'ailleurs, c'est l'appe
tous ces gens qui arrivent dans la
sphère publique. Ils sont ils sont c'est
effectivement c'est des grands
narcissistes très sûr d'eux. C'est ça
qui est agaçant. Ils ont même pas
l'humilité de dire est-ce que nous on
sait pas. Excusez-nous on a pas de
masque, c'est pas notre faux, on va en
faire. Ils disent c'est pas utile. C'est
là où ils sont ils sont de mon point de
vue, ils sont répréhensibles. Et puis
c'est des gens brillants mais pas
forcément intelligents. Voilà. Euh
l'intelligence, si je prends par exemple
dans mon métier, vous avez un scénario
comme eux, ils ont un plan, ils ont un
programme, ils ont ils ont plein
d'algorithmes, tout ça par rapport à
l'économie. C'est c'est Macron euh a
priori grand technocrate, brillant et
cetera. Start-up nation, compétitivité
internationale. Bon, c'est ses
algorithmes, c'est son schéma, c'est son
scénario. Et puis moi, je tourne ce
scénario là, j'arrive au montage et puis
les roches, ils sont pas bon. Alors,
quand les roches ils sont pas bon, faut
changer. Et j'ai le sentiment que ça
fait 3 ans que les roches ils sont pas
beaux mais ils veulent pas les changer.
Et c'est ça qui m'étonne parce que c'est
l'occasion de changer et puis quelque
part, ils ont les excuses de dire c'est
arrivé à personne n'a vécu ça. Donc on
débute, on a le droit, on va débuter
tous ensemble. Donc je comprends pas
quand ils remettent les pesticides en
service alors qu'ils peuvent trouver des
des milliards et des milliards pour des
banques mais ils trouvent pas quelques
millions d'euros pour la la filière de
la betterave. Voilà. Alors ça en tant
que citoyen ça me choque. Alors après
dès que je m'approche d'eux j'en connais
quelques-uns qui sont proches du
pouvoir, ils ont une rhtorique
implacable. Donc je je m'efface devant
cette rhtorique. C'est quoi
la rhtorique ?
Bah la rhtorique c'est le c'est
l'algorithme, c'est le calcul. C'est oui
si on met de l'argent là, on en perd là.
On en perd par rapport au sanitaires et
cetera. Mais ils ont trouvé des
centaines de milliards pour récupérer
les banques en 2008. Et puis là, ils
sont en train de réinjecter beaucoup
d'argent dans le système. Vous
connaissez ça mieux que moi. Donc je
comprends pas qu' que d'un coup si
vraiment ils avaient une conviction
écologique, ça serait tolérance zéro par
rapport à la remise en route des des
pesticides. Et comme ils ont pas cette
conviction, bah ils remettent les ils
remettent les pesticides parce que la
filière betterave, ils ont pas trouvé
l'algorithme parfait pour trouver des
sous pour pour la betterave. Il faut
évidemment aider ces gens-là aussi. Mais
dans mon idée, je me fais du politique
idéal. C'est le gars qui dit tolérance
zéro par rapport à ça. On viendra pas
là-dessus. On va protéger les
écosystèmes et comme on est super fort
en économie, vous inquiétez pas, on va
trouver des sous. D'ailleurs, comme ils
sont en train de retrouver pour relancer
l'économie, c'est ce qui se passe avec
le Covid, c'est comme si tout d'un coup
ces gens qui aiment bien qu'on joue au
Monopolie disent "On peut plus jouer
monopolie, il y a plus de sous." Et là,
ils en trouvent. Ils en trouvaient pas
pour les gilets jaunes, mais là ils en
trouvent pour ce qui se passe en ce
moment. C'est ça, j'arrive pas à les
comprendre, vous voyez, j'arrive pas à
comprendre comment ils fonctionnent. Et
encore une fois, le Covid est une
occasion de changer pour ces gens-là qui
sont encore jeunes et puis on peut
prendre le peuple à témoin de dire
"Voilà, il se passe un truc qu'on a
jamais connu. Alors, on va tous se
réfléchir ensemble. L'intelligence
collective, j'y crois beaucoup. et puis
on va changer les paradigmes. Mais ils
veulent pas changer de paradigme. À
peine sorti du confinement, il reparlent
de la de la réforme des retraites et
cetera. Je crois que c'est le MEDF qui a
dit il y a d'autres urgences pour que le
MDF dise ça, c'est que vraiment
effectivement il y a d'autres urgences.
Voilà, donc je les comprends pas
vraiment. Je comprends pas comment ils
fonctionnent et mais je prétends pas
faire mieux. Je pense la situation est
très compliquée objectivement. Voilà.
Comment vous voyez le le la situation se
déployer à 3 à 5 ans ?
Alors au début, je me disais il y a une
prise de conscience très forte, les
choses vont changer. Je l'espérais.
Là, je pense que le monde d'avant va
mettre beaucoup de temps à disparaître.
Alors, est-ce que c'est une course entre
la bêtise humaine et la nature. La
nature est très contrariée. On devait se
voir dans le sud de la France, on n pas
pu une tempête colossale. Euh, le Covid,
il fait 40°gr maintenant tous les étés.
C'est effectivement une canicule qui est
quasiment rituelle. Donc, c'est une
compétition. Voilà, je beaucoup de gens
sont passés chez vous en disant queelle
était perdue. J'espère qu'ils ont tort.
En tout cas,
on dit aussi que c'est on pouvait se
battre.
On pouvait se battre. Ouais. Mais c'est
pas le sentiment que les gens qui
gouvernent donnent. justement, ils sont
plus dans une sorte de de justement de
transhumance suicidaire. On continue à
amener le troupeau dans le mur parce
qu'on a pas d'autres solutions et
pourtant les solutions elles existent.
Justement des gens sont passés chez vous
l'ont expliqué assez clairement donc moi
je vois pas le truc chambuté parce que
moi je commence à dieu quelque part je
m'en fous je me dis bon
56 ans faut pas déconner.
Ouais mais je commence à dieu je dire
j'ai j'ai j'ai vraiment ma génération
elle est du bolon a moins que celle des
années 60 mais enfin qui était qui avait
20 ans des années 60 mais on a du bol.
Par contre j'ai des enfants quoi donc je
sais pas quoi leur dire. L'éducation,
c'est sur voilà à titre personnel,
voilà, je peux vous expliquer
l'organisation. Euh les éducations
alternatives, j'y crois beaucoup. Mon
grand garçon qui fait des études
brillantes et tout euh a fait une école
alternative. Le tout petit qui est
arrivé fait une école alternative.
Voilà, je crois beaucoup à ça. Je crois
beaucoup que que l'école, mes déviances
d'adultes, à mon avis viennent de de de
mes carences pédagogiques. Voilà. Et
pourtant, j'ai été éduqué, j'ai été aimé
et cetera. Mais il y a des carences
pédagogiques. Voilà. Et le système
encore une fois de cette [__] de
compétition, il y a une phrase de la
bourie qui dit "L'intelligence se fout
de la compétition." Et c'est totalement
vrai par rapport à ça quoi. Et l'école
nous met là-dedans et donc forcément
compétition il y a un vainqueur, il y a
beaucoup de vaincus. Donc c'est une
façon de raisonner qui est totalement
absurde. Donc voilà si d'un coup de
baguette magique je pouvais interférer
ben je dirais voilà proposons aux
instituteurs ou ceux qui veulent devenir
instituteurs deux types d'éducation.
L'éducation classique pour rassurer les
élites bourgeoises qui veulent un
système élite. Que mon fils soit le
meilleur ce qui est un peu absurde parce
que le meilleur c'est ce qui fait fond
de la planète quelque part. Et proposons
une éducation alternative. Il y en a des
vraiment des écoles très très chouettes
de plus en plus en France et qui amènent
des gamins différents. Et là dans 20
ans, vous avez des gamins qui raisonnent
totalement différemment y compris les
gamins des voilà de mettre la religion à
distance, de mettre la consommation à
distance, de mettre l'écoute de l'autre
à distance. J'ai vu des écoles où dans
dans le cahier des chars, il fallait que
20 % des effectifs soient des gamins
handicapés. Il y a pas mieux pour
apprendre à lutter contre les
différences que dès l'éducation, dès des
gamins de 5 ans de voir qu'il y a un
gamin qui est pas tout à fait pareil.
Mais la conscience là, vous comprenez ?
Je crois beaucoup à ce système là et je
parlais de de de Fred, je parlais de
Francisco Ferrer, je parlais de
Montessori. Voilà, ils ont existé ces
gens-là et souvent ils ont eu des destin
tragique pour Francisco Ferrier. Voilà,
donc c'est toujours pareil entre la
pédagogie, beaucoup de gens compris,
c'était très important et voilà si tent
qu' pas je vois pas c'est pas comment
c'est pas comme ça que je vois l'avenir
mais si tentez qu'il y a une chance à
mon avis c'est là qu' faudrait
travailler beaucoup beaucoup. Voilà.
Socialement parlant vous voyez ça
comment se déployer ? Est-ce que ça va
être 1 million de gilets jaunes par an
pendant les trois prochaines années
comme Macron nous a dit, c'estàdire 1
million de chômeurs par an
pendant minimum 3 ans.
Est-ce que vous voyez les des révoltes
sociales des
J'ai toujours vu les révoltes sociales
quand j'étais m j'ai grandi en banlieu
mon père était médecin et il me
racontait ce qui se passait déjà dans
les quartiers chantus les vignes et
cetera et je parle de ça il y a 40 ans.
Donc elles ne font que s'amplifier. Je
reviens au niveau culturel. Le problème
c'est que maintenant on partage plus la
même culture indiscutablement. Le la
pauvreté crée la modélisation a créé un
un repli identitaire très fort du
communautarisme et donc forcément on
partage plus la même culture. Et plus
partager les mêmes cultures, c'est de ne
plus avoir la même identité. Vous voyez,
c'est même pas une question
enfin voyez ce que je veux dire. C'est
ça par contre ça je l'ai vu hein
vraiment et ça ça m'inquiète parce
qu'évidemment il y a des gens qui
raisonnent totalement différemment
totalement différemment. Je ne sais pas
comment je j'apprends l'avenir. J'ai
toujours appréhendé mais j'apprends
encore plus surtout pour mégan.
Les tensions se multipli là il y a pas
longtemps. Maintenant on voit que les
mecs attaquent les flics sans aucun
problème. Les institutions se sont
tellement dédoinées derrière les
dernières décennies qui sont passées que
évidemment je vois des gens qui ne
croient plus du tout aux institutions et
qui ont même plus le respect de
l'institution. Moi, je me suis toujours
méfié des institutions, mais je les
respecte parce qu'elles me font peur.
Là, elles font même plus peur, donc
c'est en train de dégénérer. J'ai le
sentiment. Voilà. Mais encore une fois,
moi je suis un anti donc je me protège
de tout ça. Par contre, je je je sens je
sens la menace. Ouais, absolument.
Absolument.
Les violences policières,
vous en avez vu ? Vous en avez pas vu ?
Vous en avez vu sur internet ?
Les violences policières. Euh la
tragédie de l'histoire, c'est qu'elle se
répète.
Un pays qui se tient sage,
bah un pays qui se tient sage, c'est un
pays qui qui s'exprime pas.
Il y a une nuance entre les violences
policières et quelqu'un qui s'exprime.
Pourquoi faut-il dans les démocraties
modernes aller dans la rue pour se faire
entendre ? Déjà, il y a un problème,
vous êtes hyper connecté. J'arrive pas à
comprendre qu'en tant que consommateur,
je sois sollicité 100 fois par jour sur
ma tablette ou mon smartphone et qu'en
tant que citoyen, je suis consulté une
fois tous les 5 ans pour des gens qu'on
nous présente. Et le vote blanc n'y a
même pas d'effets. On arrive à des gens
comme Macron qui ont été dû, je crois
par 18 % des gens seulement. Donc ils
sont même pas légitimes. Donc voilà,
tout d'un coup, on croit plus aux
institutions, on croit plus à la
démocratie et ça crée justement le le
repli identitaire que j'évoquais avec
tout d'un coup des gens qui parle dans
tous les sens. Donc pour ça l'intérêt du
du prochain film que je voudrais faire.
Le repli identitaire va toujours de
paire avec un repli économique.
Absolument. Absolument. Absolument. euh
euh les les scénaris qu'on qu'on voit se
développer devant nous, dans 98 % des
cas, il y a un repli économique.
Pensez que les le pouvoir va se tendre
ou le pouvoir va utiliser la culture,
augmenter par deux le budget du
ministère de la culture, augmenter par
de le budget du ministère de la justice
ou des choses comme ça, il va se il va
continuer à faire perdurer ce rondrond
quotidien. Bah les 3 ans qu'on vient de
passer là sous ce gouvernement, on
montre que c'est plus dans la force et
dans et dans le respect ce qu'ils
appellent le respect de l'autorité qu'il
se font entendre. C'est pas forcément
une bonne chose. Mais quand vous parlez
de culture, moi je parle d'éducation qui
amène à la culture. C'est différent
parce que la culture il y a un côté un
peu poussiéreux dans la culture des
musées tel qu'on peut la on peut la
présenter. Alors que l'éducation dans la
culture, c'est tout à fait différent.
Mettre de l'argent là-dedans, mettre de
l'argent en éducation, oui, énorme.
C'est c'est a deux budgets, la santé,
l'éducation. C'est comme ça qu'un pays
retrouvera sa vitalité. Je sais pas ce
qui va se passer. Je je vois avec
effarmant résignation sidération le
monde est en train d'évoluer. Je vous
dis culturellement je vois que il y a
des parce que c'est malgré tout
là-dedans que je me déplace je vois
qu'il y a des blocs culturels qui sont
maintenant très différents les uns des
autres et donc il y a une paire
d'identité commune. Quand il y avait par
exemple trois chaînes de télé quand
j'étais bombe le film du dimanche soir,
on en parlait avec les avec les parents.
C'était c'était c'était même un lieu de
un lieu de partage quelque part. Il y
avait une génération qui s'affrontaient
autour d'un film et tout. Euh mon gamin
il est il m'a dit un jour on a' pas la
télé mais il m'a dit un jour c'est bien
la télé on peut voir ce qu'on a raté sur
internet
alors par contre lui a eu des images a
eu des euh a eu des des petits cluster
culturels que que j'ai pas vu. J'ai pas
partagé ça avec lui. Alors heureusement
je lui montré beaucoup de films parce
que j'aimais ça puis il aimait ça mais
il a été voir des choses que que je sais
pas ce qu'il a vu sur internet et je
sais si on peut voir des choses
épouvantables. m'a pas tout dit mais
j'ai compris qu' donc il y a une
maturation qui s'est faite socio soci
soci socioculturelle qui s'est faite en
dehors de moi quelque part une partie
son éducation m'a complètement échappé à
cause alors ces gamins quand je parle de
de cultures différentes, il y a des
générations différentes mais très
différentes. C'estd que aujourd'hui
avoir 10 ans de différence c'est c'est
phénoménal. Ça va tellement vite que à
plus vieux ou plus jeune 10 ans
différence c'est vraiment des
générations totalement c'est des
cultures, des communautés très
différentes. Ce qui va se passer, j'en
sais rien. Évidemment, il y a un
appauvrissement de la planète, mais
est-ce que c'est un appauvrissement ?
Est-ce que c'est pas plutôt le jeu
auquel on veut faire jouer les gens qui
finit par s'apauvrir et se tari ? Il
faut trouver une autre source de
communication que l'argent. Faut trouver
une autre source de de de parler aux
gens. J'aime pas dire dominer mais de
Oui. de de de dominer les gens, c'est ce
que les dominants aiment bien. Mais
autre que l'argent, l'argent commence à
être une valeur totalement périssable et
périmée. Donc je sais pas vraiment ce
qui va se passer. J'aimerais vous
répondre mais j'en sais rien. Je suis
dans l'expectative. Vous
votez ?
J'ai jamais voté pour les raisons que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure. J'ai jamais
trouvé. J'ai toujours vu des grands égos
qui m'ont toujours fait peur. Chirac
Mitteran pour la première fois et puis
après j'ai surtout vu un vote par défaut
Chirak Le Pen tout ça me sentais
vraiment pas concerné. Alors c'est pas
je me sente pas concerné par la
politique mes films peuvent quelque part
en témoigner parce que je parle des gens
donc quelque part dès qu'on parle des
gens dès qu'on prend une cause sur tous
les petites gens quelque part on fait de
la politique. Mais eux ce qu'ils font
c'est qu'ils politisent la parole
publique. Et ça c'est très différent.
Voyez l'écologie par exemple c'est c'est
un truc bizarre. Il faut être de gauche
a priori les gens de gauche sont
écologiques. J'arrive pas à comprendre
pourquoi le bateau coule. Il faut que ce
soit des gens de gauche qui a réparé la
coche. Je comprends pas. L'écologie
c'est un problème qui n'a pas de pas de
pas de raison d'avoir comment dire une
parole politique. Non, c'est l'écologie
ça concerne tout le monde ça justement
ça va être un sujet nôtre. Et il se
trouve que les grands narcises qui
veulent ce pouvoir ou qui aiment bien se
mouvoir dans la sphère publique
politiseent cette parole. Du coup
l'écologie c'est les gens de GA supposé.
Bon je comprends pas cette façon de
voir. Voilà. Bon donc je le vote m'a
toujours paru j'ai toujours été perplexe
devant le vote. Voilà.
dans Radio Les cons. Euh vous vous
abordez le le problème du de la maladie
professionnelle
de comment l'administration peut vous
aider dans la recherche d'un dossier ou
les limbes les limbes de
l'administration. Est-ce que vous avez
consulté des inspecteurs du travail, des
médecins du travail ? Est-ce que vous
avez comment vous avez préparé le
dossier de la maladie professionnelle ?
J'ai alors d'abord j'ai je traîné dans
mine pendant longtemps.
C'est ça.
J'ai fait 5 ans. Ouais.
5 ans de rouchir ?
Non je non j'étais externe. J'étais
externe et j'ai fini par être viré d'un
que je venais pas. J' beaucoup trop
cinéma. C'est ça. Vous aiez trop au
cinéma.
Voilà. Enf j'étais j'étais très absent
du service de nos patron c'était qui ?
Euh il s'appelait le professeur à
Bouker. C'est un grand professeur. Je ne
dis pas du mal de lui mais j'étais pas
beaucoup présent donc mon stage a pas
été validé
et donc voilà. Mais c'est vrai que je
comprenais pas enfin je comprenais mon
effet mérité. Elle était flagrante mais
je comprenais pas du tout encore une
fois la réalité. Je la comprenais mieux
dans l'imaginaire au cinéma. Donc euh
j'avais déjà entendu parler beaucoup ces
maladies professionnelles notamment je
me rappelle des ébénistes qui souffrent
beaucoup de cancer du sinus et je vous
parle de ça il y a 40 ans. Maintenant
c'est le pancréas chez agriculteurs à
cause des pesticides. Donc voilà la
façon de travailler excessive délirante
souvent crée des maladies
professionnelles. Je parle même pas du
stress c'est ce que pauvre mon pauvre JB
est victime de ça puisque tout d'un coup
il finit par être en pleine dépression.
Et donc effectivement les maladies
autoimmunes avec le avec les lacs, les
coiffeurs peuvent sur ça. Alors c'est on
n'est pas égau. C'est comme devant le
Covid, on n'est pas égau. Il y a des
gens qui réagissent très fort qui ont
une réponse immunitaire très forte et
puis des gens qui ont des réponses
asymptomatiques heureusement pour
l'instant la majorité des des gens ce
qui n'empêche pas de contaminer autrui.
Et donc voilà, donc je me suis renseigné
bien sûr, j'avais cette connaissance là
et plus précisément, j'ai même été au
ministère de la santé. J'ai rencontré
des même le directeur de la santé de
l'époque qui gentiment m'a reçu. Il m'a
raconté deux choses. Il m'a raconté que
les informations qu'ils avaient sur la
santé publique venaient beaucoup des
lanceurs d'alerte euh parce que bah les
laboratoires et tout, on sait que c'est
un monde assez euh bah lobilisé mais
enfin qui est assez contrôlé et c'est
pas eux qui vont dire le médicament va
pas bien. C'est beaucoup des lanceurs
d'alerte et et informatiquement il m'a
dit effectivement la vie de tout un
chacun est forcément répertorie dans
plein de fichier et si on s'amuse à
communiquer le tout en quelques clic on
peut savoir qui vous êtes et votre passé
et cetera. Voilà donc j'ai eu ces
informations là et c'est quelqu'un
d'adorable d'ailleurs qui qui que j'ai
revu par la suite. Il a vu le film il a
validé beaucoup d'aspects du film mais
voilà comment j'ai comment j'ai abordé
le projet. Vous
avez jamais vu tourner le moteur de
recherche de la DCRI ou
non on m'aurait pas laissé le faire. Je
pense pas mais j'y connais pas
grandchose donc je suis un avec des
préjugés mais qui étaient des préjugés
qui étaient effectivement en application
dans le système actuel.
Le le suicide au travail c'est aussi un
un sujet qui vous a marqué non ?
Bon c'est le burnout hein. C'est c'est
c'est tout d'un coup
suicide au fusil de chasse quand même
dans une administration. C'était quand
même bon ça.
Bah il dit qu'il veut marquer le coup.
C'est ce qu'il dit naïvement. Il dit je
marquer le coup. Je m'excuse pour les
dégâts que je vais faire et cetera. Il y
a dans la démarche du personnage il y a
quelque chose de pathétique de de il est
pas du tout habilité pour le monde
quiarrive.
Courageux. Non.
Comment
courageux ?
Oui courageux. un peu naïf aussi,
pathétique, pas courageux, je sais pas.
Oui, peut-être courageux.
Courageux quand même de se mettre un
coup de richesse.
C'est surtout très bête mais il va le
découvrir après que c'était très bête
mais
pour faire chier sa hiérarchie.
Oui, voilà. Mais c'est c'est dit d'une
façon très très modeste et très
pathétique. C'est pas un acte héroïque,
c'est ça que je veux dire quoi. Il
s'agit pas de de mettre en évidence le
suicide. C'est un acte voilà le système
l'a rendu tellement con puisque ça
s'appelle des cons qu'il finit parce
qu'il a pas son boulot par poser cet
acte complètement absurde.
Il est con, il est pas con. Mais
il est con, il est rendu Non mais il est
rendu con. Voilà. Attendez, je quand je
dis à Dieu les cons, c'est vous, c'est
moi. Mais on nous a rendu compte. Enfin,
en tout cas, moi certainement on m'a
rendu compte encore une fois carence
pédagogique. Donc voilà, lui on l'a
rendu compte parce qu'on dit voilà si tu
es performant dans ce système-là ça tout
va être bien pour toi. Il a raté les
étapes les plus importantes d'une
existence et voilà. Donc il a ce suicide
qui pour moi un geste pathétique et puis
bien sûr ça me permettait de faire
rencontrer les deux personnages d'une
façon tragiburlesque. Voilà.
Et le petit dialogue entre les deux
administrations qui dit ça va rester
entre nous.
Oui. Alors ça c'estque ça. Voilà.
C'est l'autre l'autre petit aspect du
dossier dont j'ai été voir les des gens
du raide. Je ne les nommerai pas mais
j'avais des connexions et ils m'ont dit
effectivement quand il y a un cadre
supérieur qui d'une administration un
haut responsable qui craque et cetera,
on nous demande de le récupérer en
douceur et c'est même eux qui m'ont dit
ça se fait en général à trois, il y a un
chauffeur, un chef et un costaud pour
récupérer la personne. Et voilà. Bon
mais je pense que s'ils me l'ont dit
c'est que c'est des lieux communs.
N'importe qui peut se renigner trouver
ça. Ils m'ont dit qu'un jour d'ailleurs
en Red il y a eu un enfin je pense
révéler rien du tout mais il y a eu au
cours d'exercice il y a eu un burnout
d'un d'un des gendarmes et qui a qu'à
tirer sur un collègue. Il est passé en
correctionnel à 4h du matin pour pas que
ça sache. Donc vous voyez tout d'un coup
le système peut s'arranger pour
camoufler. Par ailleurs c'est des mecs
très courageux. J'ai beaucoup de respect
pour eux les mecs du GGN aussi. souvent
j'étais les voir. C'est ça qui est qui
est qui est assez bouleversant dans le
monde qu'on traverse, c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup de bonnes volontés mais elles
sont pas forcément orientées dans les
bons sens quoi. Dans les manies, je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup de CRS qui
préfèrent faire autre chose que que
taper sur les manifestants. Maintenant,
il faut qu'il bouffent ou qu'ils élèvent
leurs enfants et cetera et cetera. Et
c'est là où le système est pervers parce
que quand je vois une manie, je vois des
pauvres qui tabassent des pauvres pour
protéger des gens infiniment plus
puissants et qui n'ont même pas subir
les conséquences de ça. C'est une vraie
tragédie. Voilà. Alors, c'est peut-être
là où la démocratie devrait se
moderniser et changer cette façon de
faire. Mais quand on regarde l'histoire
de France, c'est ces schémas existent
depuis très longtemps quoi, notamment
les misérables du goût quoi.
Comment vous vous percevez le les
attaques terroristes ?
Les attaques terroristes, ça me
terrorise de ce côté-là. Ils ont réussi.
Euh
un individu ne peut pas être qu'un
consommateur. Voilà. Et au Bataclan par
exemple, il y avait parmi les
terroristes, il y avait un chauffeur de
bus. Donc voilà, c'est quelqu'un de la
RTP, c'est quelqu'un qui fait stud en
France, qui est français, qui fait en
France et qui à un moment donné est
tellement perdu dans dans son existence
qui va dresser l'oreille à des à des
propos complètement dingues et qui va
faire qu'il a ce comportement
complètement dingue. Alors ça c'est
intéressant. Enfin c'est intéressant
c'est comment comment justement encore
une fois un système éducatif a pu passer
à côté à ce point-là dans son éducation
pour que quelqu'un soit perdu, même
devenu adulte même intégré dans un
système je crois qu'il était chauffeur
de bus à RATP et pour que tout d'un coup
cette parole là qui vient de loin qui
est une interprétation délirante d'un
texte religieux comment il peut y être
sensible pour passer à l'acte donc le
problème encore une fois je ramène ça au
tout départ quelle est la l'histoire de
ce personnage pour qu'il arrive à ça
après le terrorisme moi je trouve que
les vrais coupables Les barbares, ils
existent à toutes les générations.
Quand par exemple l'administration Bush
va en Irak pour un prétexte qui est
fallacieux, pour des histoires de faire
marcher le leur fameux lobby militaire
industriel, le pétrole et cetera, ils
ont un pays qui est sous une dictature
effroyable, c'est entendu. Ils auraient
pu faire sauter le mec avant, ils l'ont
pas fait pour des raisons géopolitiques
qui sont pas forcément absurdes
d'ailleurs puisque le pays restait
stable. Ils reviennent pour des raisons
alors pour le coup qui sont totalement
absurdes, qui sont économiques, ils
mettent le chaos dans le pays. Il y a
pas l'administration bouche, il y a pas
d'Aj. Vous comprenez le truc ? Et ce que
je comprends pas aujourd'hui, c'est que
euh les gens qui sont responsables de de
ce qui s'est passé au Bataclan, c'est
l'administration Bouche. Il y a un juge
londonien qui a dit, il faudrait juger
Tony Blair et Bouche. Vous comprenez ce
que je veux dire ? Le système, il est
quatèement dingue, c'est que vous avez
aujourd'hui des gens qui ont qui ont
généré une un chaos géopolitique
phénoménal qui fait que des barbares qui
existent à toutes les générations, tout
d'un coup des barbar s'exprime et ces
barbares portent la parole qui fait que
le seul pays d'ailleurs qui a pas
participé à la guerre, c'est les
Français entre autres qui sont victimes
de de cette parole là. Donc si on
remonte comment dire le l'origine de la
criminalité, moi c'est dans c'est dans
c'est du côté de l'administration bouche
que je suis choqué de leur comportement
et de ce qu'ils ont fait et le chaos
qu'ils ont généré. Et même si on reprend
encore une fois l'histoire de de de
l'humanité, le 20e siècle, il y a pas la
crise de 29, il y a pas Hitler au
pouvoir. Et la crise de 29, c'est déjà
du capitalisme délirant. C'est déjà un
système euh capitaliste qui n'a même pas
les protections que Rosevelt a inventé
par la suite. Ça s'appelle le Stass Act,
un truc comme ça.
Stle action
des banques d'affaires.
Voilà, ça c'est Rosal qui l'a fait. Mais
après coup à l'époque, il y a un mec qui
s'appelait qui s'appelait Hoover mais
alors c'était pas le c'était pas égard.
C'était Herbert Hoover. C'est un autre
président de la République qui
d'ailleurs est prévenu quand les taux
d'intérêt des banques ont commencé à
baisser, qui a prévenu les banques à
arrêté et les gens ne font que spéculer.
Catastrophe. C'éit en 27, il a prévenu.
En 29, il y a le craque, il y a le crac
boursier. Le craque boursier, qu'est-ce
qui se passe ? C'est une une un truc en
pyramide complet sur les communes
européennes. Et tout d'un coup, 3 ans
après, 4 ans après, Hitler est élu. Les
Américains retirent leurs avoirs dans un
pays qui est déjà en souffrance à cause
du traité de Versailles et tout d'un
coup la misère s'instale que vous
écoutez tout à l'heure, les barbares
s'expriment et après je sais pas 29 à 44
15 ans après les Américains viennent
délivrer l'Europe. Si on remonte le
schéma c'est un ego humain capitaliste à
vie. Je parle même pas la culture
américaine, c'est pas ça qui est en
cours. C'est l'ego humain qui tout
l'instrime dans une déviance qui est le
capitalisme sauvage qui crée cette cet
effet domino et qui crée un chaos
mondial. Et on retrouve ça avec ce qui
se passe avec le terrorisme puisque
c'était ça l'origine de de votre
question. Donc voilà, quand quand je on
regarde n'importe quoi au niveau de
l'histoire, on se rend compte qu'il y a
toujours un ego humain qui est fou. Là,
l'ego humain est complètement fou au
point qu'on a bouffé des des
chauves-souris, des pangolin et donc on
est en train de de bouffer la planète.
C'est le c'est la trisème guerre
mondiale qui a commencé si tôt que la
deuxième s'est arrêtée. D'ailleurs,
notamment les nitrates qui servaient à
faire des explosifs, ils ont servi à
faire du clivosate. Ils ont servi à
faire des pesticides ou des engrais. Ce
qui servait à tuer a servi à nourrir.
Ils sont fous plutôt que de de passer
ça. Enfin bref, voilà. Donc on peut en
parler longuement des des déviances
humaines, mais quand on remonte à
l'origine, on trouve toujours un ego
humain qui est fou, qui qui est mal
formé encore une fois. Voilà. Voilà. Qui
est mal formé.
Pour les prochaines élections, vous
voyez qui arriver au pouvoir ? Ah,
je rêve d'un d'un leader humaniste,
altruiste, soucieux de l'intérêt
général. Je je j'ai peur qu'on se
retrouve dans ce dans ce bipartisme
de de Macron face à face à face à un
extrémiste populaire. Je je sais pas
quoi vous dire. Je vois pas vraiment de
gens. Je trouve que Mélenchon est un mec
intéressant. En même temps, des fois il
est un peu effrayant. C'est un grand
narcisse aussi lui aussi. Mais
objectivement, c'est un très bon tribin,
c'est un type cultivé, ce qui est pas si
fréquent dans les zones politiques. Euh
bon voilà, je je sais pas s'il franchira
le le rubicon du du premier tour. Euh je
vois vraiment pas de leader. L'écologie,
moi je trouve ça intéressant, mais j'ai
l'impression que les gens, on a vu
notamment la demande écologique des des
électeurs quand on voit les grandes
villes qui sont passées justement, c'est
les écologies, mais je sais pas est-ce
que ils ont assez justement de
compétition en eux pour se rentrer dans
ce schéma là ou alors souvent les
écologistes se se se se se tirent la
bour entre eux. C'est assez étonnant
d'ailleurs, mais voilà, ce serait
peut-être bien qu'il y a un grand leader
qui porte ces valeurs là qui arrive.
Peut-être, peut-être, je sais pas. Je le
vois pas. Je vois pas pour l'instant.
Vous avez quel regard sur le traitement
médiatique, sur les journalistes, sur
comment l'histoire nous est comptée ?
Euh alors moi qui commence donc à Dieu,
euh j'ai vraiment vu la parole
médiatique changer là ces dernières
années. J'ai vraiment le sentiment que
euh toutes ces ces organes de
d'information continue sont vraiment
dans une parole euh unique en fait qui
souvent va dans le sens du pouvoir. Ça,
je suis très étonné parce que à l'époque
où il y avait une télévision d'état, il
y avait une contestation très forte dans
la télévision d'État euh France 2, enfin
c'était s'appelait Antenne 2 à l'époque,
France 3, on sentait qu'il y avait un
esprit critique très fort. C'est
vraiment plus le cas dans ces chaînes
d'info. J'étais vraiment surpris. Donc
je suis à la recherche d'information d'
c'est comme ça que je vous ai rencontré.
Euh
ah la par
c'est qui vous a fait découvrir Syerview
?
Bon c'est moi tout seul sur internet, je
cherche des choses et puis il y avait
des intervenants chez vous qui sont
passé et donc par les intervenants, j'ai
découvert j'ai découvert votre chaîne.
Mais euh la parole médiatique, elle est
elle est elle est dans la main de
quelques personnes aujourd'hui, ce qui
était pas le cas avant. En tout cas, ça
se voit beaucoup. Voilà, ça se voit
beaucoup. Euh par exemple, il y a pas
longtemps, il y a tout un une rhtorique
sur la 5G. J'ai trouvé l'intervention
justement du président, j'ai pas trouvé
ça terrible. quand il dit la 5G oui, on
va parevenir à la lampe à huile ou ou à
la méthode de vie des amis. Voilà, c'est
très dommage parce que les amis, je je
le renvoie un film qui s'appelle Witness
de Peter Vert 85 Peter Vert immense
metteur en scène australien qui toujours
dans ses films a raconté le le la
dualité entre l'écologie, les
écosystèmes et une frénésie consumériste
entre autres. Et et dans ce film
Harrison Ford, Kelly McGillis
photographie John Seal magnifique même
sur DVD, vous allez voir le travail de
photos est magnifique. Un un flic des
années 80, Harrison Ford donc
complètement soumis à cette culture
américaine quelque part délirante va
trouver refuge chez les amis. Alors
extérieurement, c'est vrai qu'ils ont un
certain folklore. On peut s'en rire, on
peut s'en amuser, c'est dommage. Ça
témoigne une étroite d'esprit. Mais le
film raconte très bien que les valeurs
dans cette communauté de pacifisme,
d'altruisme, d'humanisme sont
extraordinaires et finalement vous
résoudre le problème. Voilà. Donc plutôt
que de se moquer, il faut s'intéresser à
ce qui fait fonctionner ces gens. Leur
refus du progrès é certes un petit peu
comment dire peut pe peut paraître un
peu rigolo de l'extérieur mais les
valeurs que eux ces gens-là véhiculent
entre eux sont très intéressantes. C'est
justement les valeurs qu'on a perdu
actuellement. Et donc donc pour parler
encore une fois de ce film, le dernier
geste, il y a un gamin et le le héros
est en danger. Il tombe sur son
grand-père, le grand-père lui dit, il
lui fait il lui fait ce geste là et nous
on sait qu'il y a un pistolet dans le
tiroir. C'est formidable ce geste. Ce
geste là. Et moi je me suis dit il va
prendre le pistolet le gamin. Et ben
non, il va tirer la cloche pour prévenir
les autres. Si vous avez vu ce film,
c'est c'est juste magnifique. Voilà.
Voilà. Donc comment un film raconte
l'essentiel pour moi de de d'un être
humain, de sa valeur et tout. Et donc
c'est vraiment dommage que des leaders
se permettent de se moquer de cette
culture. Voilà, monsieur Macron,
regardez Witness. Comment
comment vous jugez euh Hollywood ?
Euh Hollywood, bah Hollywood c'est c'est
euh
terme de propagande en terme
alors ouais. Alors j'ai lu un bouquin
d'un mec qui est passé chez vous dire
qui s'appelle Jean-Pierre Connaissa,
c'est ça. Voilà. Connaiss
Pierre connaît ça. Voilà. Et il a écrit
un bouquin Hollywood Star qui est très
intéressant que j'ai lu d'ailleurs grâce
à vous et quelques petites erreurs de de
sur certains films mais c'est très
intéressant. Alors oui, il y a plusieurs
choses. Il y a il y a il y a c'est un
creuset où il y a beaucoup de génies. Il
y a des gens d'immenses talents, de
grands acteurs, de grands metteurs en
scène, de grands scénaristes qui
d'ailleurs souvent parlent de l'Amérique
avec beaucoup d'intelligence. Je
recommande la série Westwing de Haron
Sorking qui est absolument magnifique.
C'est une façon de pas de la politique
comme on aimerait qu'elle existe.
Malheureusement, c'est plus House of
Card qui s'exprime, j'ai l'impression en
ce moment. Et alors Hollywood, c'est
c'est contraignant pour la grande
culture qu'elle a d'autres. future
française quand même qui av moné le
cinéma euh il y a 100 ans, pâté Gomon
étaient les plus gros distributeurs
mondiaux, faut quand même le savoir.
Alors Hollywood, souvent les les
blockbusters, c'est souvent la victoire
d'une économie sur une culture, la
culture européenne et donc la culture
française. Mais faut reconnaître qu'il y
a énormément de talent. Beaucoup de gens
ont fait des films extraordinaires en
étant là-bas. C'est mon regret
d'ailleurs. Je cache pas qu'à une
époque, j'ai cherché un petit peu à
aller puis j'ai compris qu'ils avaient
pas besoin de moi. Donc je suis revenu
dans un endroit où moi je peux
m'exprimer en toute liberté. Mais voilà,
donc c'est deux choses, vous avez Qaron,
vous avez vous avez Kubric, vous avez
même si ces gens-là se sont mis souvent
à distance d'Hollywood, voir des gens
très fort qui ont exprimé des choses
extrêmement brillamment. Et puis vous
avez oui, vous avez les blockbusters
hebdomadaires qui quelque part font du
mal à toutes les cultures, notamment la
culture européenne. Moi je vais souvent
en Espagne, je ne vois là-bas que des
films américains. En Italie, c'est
pareil. Voilà. Alors que la la culture
européenne est une des plus la plus
grande culture occidentale qui a jamais
existé. Et et donc encore une fois quand
j'étais gamin il y a fort longtemps je
connaissais la culture italienne, je
connaissais la culture allemande parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de productions
franco-italienne, franco-espagnol,
franco et cetera et tout ça avec
l'Europe. Quand les marchands ont fait
l'Europe, la culture a été exclue. Quand
9 mois ferme les Italiens voulaient
l'acheter pour en faire un remake.
J'étais très vexé, j'ai dis mais sortez
le film. Moi je connais vos films. Je
savais qu' était Fini, Ridzi, Tonyzi et
cetera. Et il dit "Non, non, on fait un
remake. Il veul faire un remake. C'est
pas très dommage." Et c là, je l'associe
justement au repli identitair du à la
mondialisation. Maintenant, il faut
vraiment parler à ses tout proches. On
ne parle plus à personne. Mais voilà,
donc Hollywood mais correspond la
culture est à l'image d'une société là.
L'impérialisme américain, c'est un peu
con dire ça, mais la frénésie américaine
de dominance s'exprime beaucoup par la
par rapport à Hollywood. Il y a beaucoup
de propagande dans Hollywood bien
évidemment et surtout ce qui est
terrible dans dans les grands films
hollywoodiens, mais alors je parle des
blockbusters, je pas c'est qu'ils
vendent d'un une façon de penser, ils
vont d'un manquéisme dans lequel il y a
un dominé, un dominé, un dominé et puis
souvent résout les problèmes par la
force. Alors ça c'est c'est dommage de
la part d'Hood. C'est pas ce qu'il y a
de mieux chez Hollywood mais Hollywood a
généré quelque part Terry Guilam a
généré les frères Cohen a généré
beaucoup Ven a fait une carrière
magnifique aux États-Unis renvoyé
Robocop une fois passé le cinéma
d'action on voyait une vraie critique du
monde que lui il connaît et qu'il
fréquente dans les années 80 donc voilà
c'est c'est quand même le creuset a il y
a beaucoup de talent faut-il encore que
ce talent puisse s'exprimer voilà
comment je vois Hollywood
c'est
le le Pierre de le le bouquin de Pierre
connaissa, il est sympa il écrit
d'autres d'ailleurs sont intéressant il
il est il est il est très il est très
caustique.
Comment vous on va revenir sur les les
journalistes et les médias euh vous êtes
fait emmerder il y a de 3 ans pour les
histoires de loyer d'un d'un bâtiment
insalubre et euh le truc était juste à
côté des salles de rédaction. Vous avez
pas vu un seul journaliste.
Alors je je fais un petit petit synopsis
de l'histoire. Donc en fait
effectivement je loue à l'Île-de-France
un hôtel particulier désaffecté. On
avait fait ça sur 9 mois. On a récidivé
sur voila à l'époque on devait partir
squaté l'hôtel particulier déjà
non on avait juste loué pendant un an
avant avant vous
non avant il était désaffecté c'était
une il y a eu une école de maquillage
qui était en fait le bâtiment était
fermé depuis 2008 on les a sollicité en
2012 ils ont été très réactifs vraiment
je remercie les administrations de notre
quelle que soit la gouvernance les gens
qui s'occupaient de ça ont été très
réactifs et donc ils nous ont proposé ce
lie voilà surtout filmerz-le et il
voulait faire un loyer gratuit et on
voulait pas parce qu'on emploie des gens
pour les assurances fallait au moins
qu'on ait un petit loyer Ils ont enfoué
qui était ridicule objectivement.
Maintenant le lieu
1200 €
1000 et quelques euros 1200 € mais le
lieu était totalement désaffecté. Il y a
plus d'eau, il y avait plus
d'électricité, il y a plus bien sûr pas
internet, il a fallu réinstaller le le
la chaudière, le tout à l'égoute. Donc
on a eu des frais pour s'installer là
mais dans dans dans la calculette,
c'était une bonne affaire de s'installer
là. C'était tout près de mes bureaux en
fait qui sont juste à côté. Donc voilà,
c'était une bonne affaire. Donc on a
loué ce bâtiment. Ce qui est intéressant
c'est que donc le responsable m'a dit
"Écoutez, c'est bien mais fimez-le parce
que c'est du patrimoine." Et la
référence par rapport au loyer, c'était
on ne veut pas faire d'argent sur le
patrimoine culturel. C'était une très
bonne chose. Voilà, j'ai trouvé ça très
bien. Puis vu l'état du lieu
effectivement, on a compris quand on a
visité qu'il y avait beaucoup de boulot.
Bref, on s'est installé dans ce lieu et
il m'avait dit tourner quelque chose. Je
pensais faire quelques insertes,
quelques gros plans et puis en fait le
lieu était super. On a tourné
pratiquement sur 6 semaines de tournage.
On était 3 semaines dans ce bâtiment
avec un décorateur ingénieux et puis de
la mise en scène, on s'est débrouillé.
Bref, beaucoup de neuf mois fermes.
C'est ce bâtiment en question. On a
restitué le bâtiment, on devait faire au
revoir là-haut en Hongrie. La loi a
changé grâce à Baisson, faut le dire.
Tout d'un coup le le le crédit d'impôt
est arrivé sur des films avec des gros
budgets alors que c'est c'était le cas
d'envo et pas sur les films à petits
budget. Donc on a pu bénéficier de ce
crédit d'impôt et donc on est revenu en
France quelque part à 2 mois ou 3 mois
du tournage. J'ai dû refaire tous mes
décors et cetera. Enfin bref, l'aventure
d'un film et euh et donc on a
resollicité le bâtiments qui étaient
encore vides. On nous l'a reloué pareil
un tarif au dérisoire. On s'est
réinstallé dans ce lieu qu'on aime
beaucoup forcément. On a commencé à
avoir d'histoire avec ce lieu. On a
préparé, on a tourné, on a monté, on a
post-produit et au moment de rendre ce
lieu, on apprend alors je sais pas par
quel biais que je suis chassé de bons
d'hôtel particuliers que Valérie PCRES
qui m'avait appelé pendant le tournage
pour me dire "L'hôtel est en vente mais
rassurez-vous, on sait que vous tournez
un film, gardez-le". On a même réussi à
avoir la subvention d'Île-de-France pour
vous dire à quel point marcher main dans
la main. On apprend qu'elle m'expulse de
mon hôtel particulier que je payeraai un
montant dérisoire.
Apprend c'est dans la presse.
Dans la presse vo un soir ça sort au
début
comment s'appelle le journaliste qui a
écrit ça ?
Je sais pas. C'est un truc qui a sorti
euh peut-être que vous le retrouvez
mieux que moi et au début on réagit pas
parce qu'on trouve ça absurde. On attend
des mentilés de France qui ne vient pas
objectivement. Je sais pas s'ils ont été
pas très réactif par rapport à ça et
puis au bout d'un moment je veux dire on
attend les journalistes parce qu'on est
en plein Paris, il y a bien quelqu'un
qui va venir vérifier. Et ben pas du
tout, personne n'est venu. Et j'ai
entendu sur des radios compignons sur
rue ta ta tatin, vous reconnaîtrez le
jingle, l'acteur réalisateur du pontel
est viré de son hôtel particulier qu'il
payait, tenez-vous bien, 1200 € par
mois. et et tout de suite la parole à un
député des Républiques hein, je crois et
on entend un mec euh crier sa colère et
sa rage et sa frustration mais personne
n'est venu me voir pour visiter le lieu.
Personne. C'est ça qui est étonnant. Et
le truc a été relayé partout sur les
réseaux sociaux. C'était je crois sur
Twitter le le truc le plus lu après
l'envoi du missile nord-coréen audessus
du Japon. C'est pour vous dire quand
même quoi. Alors ça duré 3 jours,
c'était ridicule, ça s'est éteint tout
seul. Moi ça m'a fait beaucoup de mal
parce que objectivement je rase les murs
dans cette profession. Je je ne veux que
faire des films, pas autre chose. Et
puis c'était totalement injuste où ça
avait été fait en toute coordination. Et
c'est là où j'ai vu effectivement que la
formation
avait beaucoup changé, que le clic était
plus important que qui était plus
important que la formation. On vous dit,
on était vraiment on est en plein Paris
quoi. Il y avait encore les tables de
montage, il y avait encore puis le lieu
est un salub. Il y a pas de il y a pas
de salle de bain, il y a rien. Et
d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs ce on l'a
réussi à le retrouver pour les cons.
L'île-de-Fance nous l'a reloué, on a
retravaillé et on l'a rendu ces
jours-ci. Talement on doit le rendre ces
jours-ci. le Covid un petit peu arrêté
mais c'est pour vous dire tout a été
fait pour une fois qu'une administration
ça se passait bien enfin c'était
vraiment je trouve que l'administration
prenait tout son sens par rapport au
fait d'offrir un lieu qui est un lieu
public pour un tournage. C'était bien,
il a fallu que on pervertisse ce trucl
mais que des gens invent, c'est dans
c'est la loi du genre mais que personne
soit venu vérifier. Alors ça ça m'a un
peu bluffé. Ouais. Du coup méfiance sur
les médias décuplé à titre personnel.
Voilà.
Pourquoi vous dites
que vous rasez les murs dans la
profession ?
Euh j'estime que je je comment dire je
je veux bien prendre la parole à travers
un film. J'ai pas envie de prendre la
parole sur un plateau ou dans ou dans la
sphère publique. Je trouve ça pas très
élégant. Je suis pas forcément très à
l'aise. J'ai la chance de faire des
films. On me donne des sous pour faire
des films. Euh donc je raconte beaucoup
de choses quand même. Déjà je cruis, je
joue, je filme. Si en plus il faut que
j'aille raconter mon point de vue sur
tous les plateaux, c'est un peu de la
triche quelque part. C'est pas très
élégant. J'ai pas envie de saouler les
gens plus que ça quoi. Donc voilà, on va
être un petit peu peut-être battu par le
Covid pour la sortie. Mais au moins, je
trouvais que le film c'est une façon
élégante de s'exprimer. Voilà, on on
propose et le public dispose. Euh voilà,
c'est ce que j'appelle raser les murs
parce que il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
sollicitations et pour pour parler en
temps normal et c'est pas un truc qui
m'intéresse beaucoup quoi à part ici.
Voilà.
Vous faites
Il y a un temps de parole qui est qui
est plutôt intéressant ici. Nous,
on est très content de vous recevoir
parce que vous avez participé à notre
éducation.
Très bien. Je suis si vieux que ça.
Voyez, vous dites que je suis pas vieux.
Je commence à l'aide quand même.
Berny Noël était était un vrai choc.
Qu'est-ce que Qu'est-ce que On va
prendre quelques questions d'Internet.
Ouais.
Euh je vais la piocher si j'arrive à
attraper la ligne au hasard.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu parler
de la désobéissance civile hashtag laron
?
Euh deobéissance civile, j'ai entendu
parler bien sûr, je connais le concept.
Hashtag larons, je le connais pas.
Encore une fois, je suis pas broché de
réseau, mais je comprends très bien que
des gens se posent la question. Il y a
des gamins qui ont été s'enchaînés il y
a pas longtemps Boulever Saint-Germain
et rébillon.
Ouais, mais je peux comprendre ça. Il y
a tellement pas d'action. Il y a
tellement pas de d'agissement, c'est des
gens qui gouvernent, qui communiquent
beaucoup mais qui agissent très peu.
Alors après la question que je me
posais, est-ce qu'ils peuvent agir ?
C'est là où je me pose la question
justement des des lobbyes, des réseaux
de de leur formation, de leurs
convictions. Est-ce qu'ils peuvent agir
? Est-ce qu'ils sont pas empétrés dans
un schéma intérieur ? Est-ce qu'on peut
les laisser agir ? Des fois, on se dit
quand on veut leur pardonner, on dit ils
peuvent pas agir les pauvres gars. Moi,
je pense qu'ils peuvent agir. Le coût du
pesticide quand même dit vous chariz
quand même, faut pas remettre ce truc là
en circulation. Donc la désobéissance
civile qui consiste à aller bloquer une
rue, j'espère qu'ils ont pas été évacués
trop violemment. Voilà, je comprends les
gamins, il reste plus que ça. Moi,
j'aurais 20 ans, certainement c'est des
choses que je ferai aujourd'hui quoi.
C'est c'est l'impuissance de la parole
citoyenne.
Souvent, c'est intéressant dans dans
dans des gilets jaunes et puis d'autres
gens dans la convention citoyenne, c'est
la demande de référendum. Pourquoi on
pourrait pas s'exprimer par rapport à ça
? Alors, les les politiques nous disent
"Mais non, il y a une assemblée
législative qui est là pour ça." Elle
est a fait complètement pouvoir en
place. Et tous les 5 ans, ils ont réussi
même à supprimer la législative à
mi-mandat qui était un truc intéressant.
Le premier qui a trahi la cause
d'ailleurs, c'est quelque part, c'est
mitant. Il aurait dû partir en 86, il
est resté au pouvoir. Il habitait cette
perte d'énergie d'argent puisque c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont fait maintenant
législative en même temps que le
présidentiel. À l'arrivée, vous avez un
gars qui est plein pouvoir pendant 5 ans
et nous on n'a pas la parole quoi. Et je
comprends pas ça. On pourrait vous êtes
mieux placé que moi pour savoir
solliciter des gens par internet mais
même dans sa vie pour savoir si on est
d'accord pour la pistyclable pour savoir
pour d'accord l'ouverture d'une école ou
d'un McDo à la sortie d'un lycée comme c
arrivé dans dans mon dans mon village.
Voilà voilà pour être sollicité. Je
demande pas mieux moi de participer à la
vie citoyenne comme ça. Le vote j'en
vois pas l'utilité. Je suis pas d'accord
avec le principe. Je trouve qu'il nous
vole quelque part nos opinions et ce
qu'ils appellent la démocratie à grand
renfort de de déclarations trépidantes.
Et donc voilà le le on devrait être
sollicité régulièrement en tant que
consommateur autant en tant que citoyen.
Voilà, on devrait sans arrêt être
sollicité. Plein de gens y répondraient,
plein de gens participeraient à la vie
citoyenne si c'était fait comme ça. Et
je pense que techniquement c'est
faisable. Ils vont brandir le fait que
on pourrait pirater et cetera. C'est sûr
que ça doit exister, mais je pense qu'on
peut pirater aussi dans les isoloirs.
Donc pour voilà, pourquoi ne pas être
sollicité en tant que citoyen.
Les grosses chaussettes.
Euh on on va parler, je vais prendre une
question. A-t-on affaire à un
effondrement de notre société ? Donc ça
c'est la question de Claris. Vous avez
tourné avec Bastien Hugeto.
Oui.
Qu'on connaît.
Excellent acteur
qui qui euh qui bossait avec les qui bos
toujours avec les parasites.
J'ai appris ça.
Euh est-ce que vous avez vu la série sur
l'effond de Roman ? Non mais j'ai lu le
bouquin de Jarry Diamond effondrement il
y a déjà fort longtemps. Donc j'ai tout
lu de Jarry Diamond. Je recommence très
intéressant. Il est d'ailleurs critiqué
beaucoup, je sais pas pourquoi. Euh de
l'inégalité parmi les sociétés est un
film un livre vraiment fondateur en ce
qui me concerne et fondement annoncent
oui voilà. Alors est-ce que c'est
vraiment l'extinction ? Encore une fois
je crois au génie humain, je crois à
l'individu je crois aussi à la bêtise
dès qu' dès qu'il est groupé en masse
mais j'arrive pas à croire qu'on qu'on
va disparaître même si effectivement
c'est c'est un peu effrayant. Alors, je
ne sais pas par contre vous faites
référence à Bastien, j'ai pas vu euh ce
ce son documentaire ou ou sa fiction sur
les fonds d'Amon. Un
truc un truc sorti sur Canal Plus. Euh
euh autre question d'internet, que
penses-t-il de Black Lee Matters ?
Bah c'est une protestation euh du de des
opprimés par rapport aux oppresseurs.
Euh qu'est-ce que je pense ? Je suis pas
noir. Donc maintenant ça me Je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure de du choc que j'ai
vu, enfin que je voudrais d'ailleurs
parler de à travers une dystopie quelque
part de de Robert Kennedy. C'est très
intéressant. Donc voilà, c'est aucun
noir américain n'est venu dans dans ce
pays historiquement, volontairement. Il
est venu à travers un des pires crimes
de l'humanité qui s'appelle l'esclavage.
Donc et cette oppression d'ailleurs, je
vous recommande le 13e amendement. Je
sais pas si vous avez vu le documentaire
qui est absolument excellent. Vous az
pas vu de 13 amendement. C'est
extraordinaire ce truc là. Et donc c'est
justement voilà, ils expliquent même si
Lincoln après la la sécession a abolé
l'esclavage, l'esclavage a continué à
travers d'autres formes. Donc c'est très
compliqué. C'est très compliqué. Black
Liv Mat gens encore une fois qui
protestent qui protestent comme ils
peuvent maladroitement forcément.
Ane question d'internet. Que
pensent-t-il de la liberté d'expression
dans les films dont ce qu'il peut faire
?
Euh moi j'ai toujours fait honnêtement
ce que j'ai voulu. Berni j'ai fait avec
très peu d'argent. Quand on voit le film
on comprend. Mais à l'époque, il y avait
quand même des gens qui nous aidaient
beaucoup. C'était l'époque du Grand
Canal Plus. Et alors ça Ouais, de Gref,
ça c'était quelqu'un qui comptait
beaucoup. Alors Degref était directeur
des programmes de Canal et était surtout
un monteur de cinéma au départ. Donc
c'était un instruit, un cinéfil. C'est
pas si fréquent la télé, même quasiment
rarissime. Et il a beaucoup encouragé
des des gens comme moi Gaspar Noé, Yann
Conen et cetera. C'était un peu la même
génération. Et donc il y avait une
source de respiration avec ce ce grand
Canal Plus des années 90. Et donc Berni,
j'ai fait très peu d'argent parce
qu'évidemment le film d'ailleurs n'est
jamais passé sur une chaîne en clair et
était mais c'était il était voulu comme
ça. Après c'est pas que j'ai cherché
avoir plus d'argent. D'ailleurs ce film
là il coûte beaucoup moins cher que Adon
coûte beaucoup moins cher qu'en Valau.
C'est juste que les sujets n'ont pas
forcément besoin de beaucoup d'argent
par rapport à ça. Mais j'ai jamais été
brimé, il faut bien le savoir. J'ai
jamais été brimé dans on m'a jamais dit
supprime ça. Jamais jamais.
La liberté d'expression en France, ça va
comment ?
Bah elle va pas très bien quand on tue
des mecs parce qu'ils ont caricaturé le
prophète. Là c'est une catastrophe quoi.
La laïcité. Il y a des millions de gens
qui sont morts pour ça en France surtout
dans ce pays. C'est vraiment le pays la
liberté d'expression. Moi j'étais
effondré c'est là où je parle de choc
des cultures, des gens qui raisonnent
différemment. Il y a certainement une
responsabilité politique antérieure par
rapport à ça mais elle devient Ouais
mais c'est c'est fondamental. C'est
alors s'il y a tenter qu'il y a une
identité dans ce pays c'est la liberté
d'expression. Mais vraiment quand vous
regardez, vous montez au 10e siècle, les
caricatures de Domier, de Gustave Doré
et cetera, c'est très très fort ce
qu'ils avaient raconté et et donc que ce
soit tout d'un coup remis en cause parce
que tout d'un coup les gens se
comprennent plus et cetera. Ça c c'est
c'est ma terreur. C'est ma terreur.
Alors il y a une question euh
comment va Monique ? Ça veut dire quoi
ça ?
Je sais pas, je sais pas. J'espère que
je vais pas je vais pas sortir sur Mou.
Je ne connais pas de Monique.
Mou alors ?
Bah Mitou encore une fois c'est une
parole de de d'opprimé par rapport à des
oppresseurs. Voilà. après qu' a pas des
déviances, des excès peut-être
certainement. Voilà maintenant c'est
bien que cette parole existe, c'est
bien. Après on est toujours surpris
quand on n pas concerné de voir qu'on a
besoin de cette prise de parole pour que
cette chose existe parce que ça nous
paraît une évidence. Donc voilà, tout
black matter c'est une façon de
gonflable.
Ah oui, c'est un film que j'ai fait en
tant que pardon. C'est un film que j'ai
fait. Au moins, c'est quelqu'un qui qui
n'embête pas sa femme puisqu'il sort
avec une poupée gonflable. Voilà.
Et Momo, comment va Momo ?
Momo, oui, le chat Momo. B Momo, il est
toujours Il est toujours en paillé.
Toujours. Question d'internet.
Connaît-il Krishna Murti ?
Euh non, mais peut-être que je connais
euh ce qu'il a fait ou ce qu'elle a
fait.
Ce qui c'est un philosophe indien.
Ah non, je connais pas.
Quels sont ses acteurs préférés et quels
sont ceux avec lequel il a préféré
tourner ?
Les acteurs préférés, c'est souvent des
acteurs morts.
Ma vedette, moi c'est c'est Michel
Simon. J'adore Michel Simon. J'aime
beaucoup Jouvet, Gabin bien sûr et
cetera. Les acteurs des années 30 m'ont
toujours fasciné parce que à peine le
cinéma français existait que déjà il y
avait des grands acteurs et des grands
formalistes carnet du vivier roi noir.
Voilà, je bibronne beaucoup à ce à ce
cinéma là. Euh j'adore j'ai j'ai croisé
le grand Belmondau. J'adore Belmondau.
Voilà, j'ai grandi avec Belmondau. Il a
il a été une bouffée d'air frais pendant
l'enfance, l'adolescence. Et puis j'ai
rencontré un individu qui est
extrêmement raccord avec ce que
j'imaginais lui qui prône l'insouciance
comme comme vertu de vie, une élégance
de communication. Jean-Paul ne se plaint
jamais, il faut le savoir même si la vie
commence beaucoup à l'atteindre. Euh
alors à qui j'aimerais tourner ? Avec
qui j'ai aimé tourner, c'est ça ?
Bah les acteurs du dernier film, j'ai
beaucoup aimé tourner avec Nicolas
Marier. J'adore cet acteur, j'adore.
Virginie, c'était très bien. Elle elle a
amené sur le plateau des tonnes
d'émotions don dans don courageusement
baise. Elle est elle est balaise
franchement. Ouais, elle alors le petit
parcours qu'elle a fait lâchement, je me
suis pas renseigné, je me suis contenté
de filmer comme un salvoyeur mais j'ai
bien vu répétition que dès le départ il
y avait des choses à dire à travers les
larmes et voilà. Donc j'ai pas trop
travaillé ce secteur là, sachant que
devant la caméra, ça serait très bien.
Et puis par contre, on a bossé de la
comédie et cetera. Voilà, donc Virginie,
Nicolas et puis les acteur qu'on voit
souvent dans mes films, Philippe
Luchant, Viller Hermos, c'est des gens
qu' on se connaî depuis 30 ans et on a
tout fait ensemble, des bêtises, des
choses bien, on s'est fâché, on s'est
réconcilié, donc je sais c'est un
réservoir. C'est des grands acteurs,
voilà, c'est pas forcément les plus
connus mais c'est des grands acteurs.
Après parmi les gens connus, j'ai adoré
bosser Bliz. J'adore Blier, c'est le
dernier poète vivant de notre langue.
Bertrand Bliz. Ouais. Ouais, c'est ça.
C'est vraiment un mec que que je vénère.
Euh, j'ai adoré bosser Becker dans notre
registre. J'aime beaucoup la sincérité
de Becker qui revendique un terroir mais
avec beaucoup de sincérité, il l'assume
complètement. Ça c'était des metteurs en
scène. Et puis après, j'ai beaucoup de
d'acteurs que j'ai fréquenté et j'ai
beaucoup apprécié le leur compagnie
quoi.
Autre question internet. Reviendrait-il
sur scène pour financer un film ?
Euh, la scène c'est c'est rigolo parce
que c'est la c'est la c'est la seule
porte qui s'est ouverte quand quand
j'étais jeune. J'ai fait une école, une
école de théâtre, une grande école de
théâtre. Vitesse, c'était l'école de
Chaillot, il y a Vitesse grand mteur en
scène, individu extrêmement cultivé qui
parlait cinq langues, donc grec ancien
et puis qui avait été le secrétaire
d'Aragon. Donc voilà, c'était un puit de
culture. Grâce à lui, j'ai découvert
TKOV, j'ai découvert Shakespeare, j'ai
découvert même Molia, j'y connaissais
rien et mais pour mon identité
personnelle, je faisais des petits
sketches qui faisait rigoler les copains
et puis c'était une façon pour moi de
son contreculture par rapport à la
culture officielle. Voilà, c'était un
peu mon identité à moi dans dans
l'école. J'ai fréquenté aussi la grande
Mouchine qui était peut-être la plus
grande pédagogue, la plus grande metteur
en scène que j'ai rencontré. Elle
pourrait donner Ouais. 10 jours, mais
elle pourrait donner de la vie à la
matière morte tellement elle est forte.
Elle est extraordinaire cette femme,
extraordinaire vraiment je pèse mes
mots. Allez voir les spectacles d'Arien,
c'est juste extraordinaire. Bref, et
puis voilà et puis Vitesse à la sortie
de l'école devient administrateur de la
colonie française.
Il prend des élèves et puis moi il me
prend pas. Voilà, je me retrouve avec
mon petit bagage de sketch justement à
éructes,
des campings, des restaurants. Voilà,
c'était il y a 30 ans d'ailleurs. Et
voilà. Donc mais je suis ça malgré tout
je m'accroche à ça et puis un jour un
coup de téléphone un peu comme vous coup
de téléphone est-ce que vous viendriez
faire pas un sketch pas un interview
mais un sketch dans dans une émission de
variété celle de Sébastien. Je sais
qu'elle existe. J'ai pas de télé mais
j'en sais pas plus et je demande combien
combien vous en plus ils ont vu une
cassette, c'est même pas moi qui l'ont
envoyé. C'est ça qui est assez c'est
assez c'est ça qui est assez curieux et
j'ai dit combien vous donnez quoi. Alors
je sais pas c'était l'équivalent de 5
600 € pour le sketch et avec ça je
pouvais tenir 6 mois à l'époque. Donc je
me retrouve sur ce plateau. Alors je
passe des lambri dorées de Chaillot au
camping sauvage où c'est mes sketch aux
danseuses au seindu au dresseur de fo
intéressant et je trouve un personnage
certes ambigu mais extrêmement
chaleureux très généreux et qui en tout
cas moi me traite avec beaucoup de
respect et puis propose à son meilleur
copain Olivier Guilla je salue la
mémoire de s'occuper de mon spectacle.
Voilà, donc à peine le sketch fait, ils
me disent voilà, on a un petit théâtre à
Paris et voilà donc c'est la seule porte
qui s'ouvre à ce moment-là. Voilà mon
petit parcours peut-être que je vous le
résume et je franchement je suis pas
bégueul, je m'amuse beaucoup. J'aime pas
la télé indiscutablement. J'aime pas
faire des sketchs chez la télé mais
j'aime bien les faire sur scène surtout
quand les salles sont pleines et pour
que les salles soient pleines, il faut
montrer un petit peu son est rouge à la
télé. Voilà, donc ça a duré 18 mois
exactement et après j'ai salué, j'étais
un peu connu, j'avais des sous et
j'avais aucune raison de ne pas faire ce
que je voulais à savoir des films. Voilà
et les sous du spectacle m'ont permis de
faire un courtmétrage s'appelle Désiré
qu'on peut voir sur YouTube qui est
vraiment un premier hommage à Brésil.
Donc je ne dirai jamais assez à quel
point ce film a été fondateur et donc je
ne reviendrai pas sur scène si ce n'est
quand je serai mort, je ferai une
tournée dans les cimetières. Voilà. Mais
là pouvoir faire des films. C'est
vraiment une chance et j'espère pouvoir
continuer à l'avoir cette chance. Voilà.
Pourquoi il y a pas de grandeur sans
tristesse ?
Ça c'est une phrase de rabel. Euh mais
je la trouve assez juste cette phrase.
Je sais pas ce que vous en pensez. Je
sais pas si vous connaissez un peu
l'œuvre de Ravel. Il y a un morceau qui
s'appelle, il y en a deux morceaux, il y
a le concerto en sol et puis les pavanes
pour une informe défintes. Voilà que
rien de les écouter, on comprend la
phrase. Il y a pas de grandeur sans
tristesse. Et donc euh bah oui, cette
phrase me hanit parce que quelque part
la grandeur enfin la tristesse peut vous
enfin je sais pas comment le formuler
justement. Euh on peut pas être on peut
pas être grand dans la comédie pure. Il
y a toujours les les les les grands
comiques, si on prend Chapeline, c'est
toujours un drame qui vous raconte. Donc
il y a de la tristesse dans l'histoire
de Chapline. Dans le kit, c'est triste.
Dans l'humeur de la ville, c'est triste.
Et il devient grand parce que de cette
tristesse, il va non seulement nous
distraire, bien sûr, mais il va faire
des actes héroïques. Et j'adore ces
personnages là. J'adore les petits bons
hommes qui de univers d'univers triste
comment est en train de vivre où ce
raconte dans un dieu les cons vont
devenir grand par le acte. Être un héros
des chches, c'est faire ce qu'on peut.
Voilà. Alors, c'est ce que je fais à mon
niveau et et voilà. Donc, il y a pas de
grandeur sans tristesse et ben de de la
tristesse naîtra de la grandeur. Je
renverserai la phrase plus exactement.
Mais cette phrase m'a hté pendant
l'écriture de Dieu les con et
inévitablement a amené sur la fin. Je
sais pas ce que vous en avez pensé. On
en parlera peut-être pas la fin.
On en parlera après exactement.
Non non, on spoile pas sans déconner. Il
faut
c'est un bon moment.
Ouais. Non mais justement voilà c'est
cette phrase ma guidé elle est pendant
les
donc les con c'est une tragédie
burelesque. C'est un mélange de molière
et de racine.
C'est ça.
En toute prétention voilà c'est ce que
toute prétention. Bah c'est de mélanger
des genres qui a priori s'opposent.
Voilà pour moi il y a qu'un seul
classique au cinéma. Et d'ailleurs les
quelques jours que j'ai fait avec la
grande mouche, elle rappelait sans arrêt
l'intérêt de de Chapeline au cinéma. Et
ben voilà, c'est c'est c'est de dire "Je
vais vous raconter une histoire triste
mais malgré tout, je vais être
distrayant." Donc la mort, je prends ça
comme un lieu commun dans le film mais
je vais pas en débattre, je vais pas je
vais pas la diaboliser, je vais pas
pleuricher. C'est un film qui parle de
la mort mais avec beaucoup de vie.
Voilà. Donc les héros pendant 48 heures
vont vivre très très fort plus que toute
leur vie. Voilà ce que ça raconte.
Voilà. Tragédie burlesque.
Euh on va reprendre une question
d'internet. Euh question de politique.
Tu connais François Ruffin Albert ?
Ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais. Je trouve
François Rin. Je l'ai vu chez vous et
j'ai souvent été chercher ces
interventions à la semaine nationale. Je
trouve le personnage très intéressant,
très sincère. J'ai vu un autre
personnage grâce à vous d'ailleurs,
c'est j'ai rencontré François Boulot,
l'avocat des gilets jaunes parce que là
aussi, je voudrais vraiment qu'il me
file un coup de main pour ce prochain
scénario que j'aimerais écrire. Voilà,
donc grâce à vous, j'ai rencontré tous
ces gens-là. Ruffin, je le connaissais
par la rumeur publique et j'ai vu
d'ailleurs son ces deux documentaires,
je veux du soleil et merci patron. Et à
chaque fois, j'ai trouvé ça très
intéressant une fois de plus. C'est des
paroles nécessaires, c'est des paroles
certes parfois brouillonnent, parfois
maladroite, mais c'est des périodes
absolument nécessaires, sincère,
convaincante, touchantes et mouvantes.
Et il faut qu'on entende ces gens-là
parler. Voilà. Bon, est-ce qu'ils sont
faits que pour parler ? Est-ce qu'ils
sont faits que pour gouverner ? Je ne
sais pas. Des fois, je vous dis ça
pourra pas être pire s'il gouvernait.
Autre question internet. Que pensent-il
du roi et l'oiseau ? Film d'animation de
1980 ?
Ouais, c'est le grand dessin animé
français. Magnifique. Magnifique. C'est
peut-être le plus grand chez l'œuvre du
dessin animé français. Il y a deux chef
d'œuvres au dessin animé. Il y a toute
l'asaki que je vous recommande si vous
des gamins, c'est juste magnifique mais
elle est très connue. Il y a des choses
moins connues. Il y a le tombeau des
luciol qui est le seul dessin animé qui
m'a fait pleurer. Si vous l'avez vu, je
suis pas seul à avoir pleuré ce dessin
animé. Et le roiseau c'est juste
magnifique. Voilà, c'est une œuvre
magistrale de la culture française, du
cinéma français. Grand dessin animé
français.
Question internet. Cédric Irou est le
principe de fraternité. Qu'en pense-il ?
Pardon ?
Cédricou est le principe de fraternité.
Vous savez, Cédricou, c'est le monsieur
qui recueille des gens qui traversent la
montagne en plein hiver dans
les migrants. Ouais.
Euh et ben ça ça serait bien si c'était
organisé. Le problème de faire ça, c'est
se mettre dans l'illégalité, c'est là où
ça va pas. Voilà, la démarche est
fondée. La méthode pas forcément puisque
forcément il seorte, je crois qu'il est
du tas de souci administratif lui aussi
par rapport à ça. Mais on est condamné à
accueillir ces gens-là qui viennent du
sud. votre un de vos intervenants Giro
est très pessimiste sur le réchauffement
de la planète donc il prévoit une
migration phénoménale donc on est
condamné à les accueillir autant on
s'adapter très vite autant se mettre au
point par rapport à ça parce que c'est
pas l'immigration qui est un problème
c'est l'intégration qui est un problème.
Et là, on revient un de mes clusters
favoris, c'est l'éducation. Donc,
l'immigration est inévitable.
L'intégration, il faut vraiment
travailler dessus le plus possible pour
préserver cette culture qui est la nôre.
Voilà,
le cinéma de le cinéma du Pontel met en
scène et sublime les petites gens
souvent dans leur misère. Que pensent-il
des films récents qui observent la vraie
vie des gens comme La Cravate ou Les
Misérables ?
Alors, la cravate, je l'ai pas vu. Les
misérables, je l'ai vu. Je trouvais ça
magnifique. Voilà. Et la seule chose des
misérables, c'est que c'est pas neuf.
Voilà. Regardez toute l' de Knouche. Ça
fait 40 ans que Kenche raconte les
petits gens. Je vous renvoie un de mes
films favoris Kenlo, c'est Ladybird. Et
je trouve que les Misérables est un est
un succès d'années de Ken façon
franco-française faite par quelqu'un si
j'ai bien compris qui a grandi dans ces
cités aussi. Et j'ai adoré la sincérité,
j'ai adoré la vérité. C'est un film à
tout petit budget qui est extrêmement
bien mis en scène qui m'a énormément
touché. J'ai vu deux fois ce film et
voilà. Donc c'est une il prorogge les
documentaires de de pardon là aussi qui
sont fouillant que j'ai vu quand j'étais
jeune. Je pense des flagrant, je pense
sa 10e chambre. Toute l'œuvre de Kenche
est à voir et dans cette lignée là, il y
a les arabes qui s'inscrivent et voilà
donc c'est des films à voir, films
extrêmement éducatifs. Il paraît qu'il a
coupé la fin, que le gamin ne jette pas
le mol jetait le molotop, il l'a coupé,
il a bien fait. Il laisse la question
chez les spectateurs.
Question internet. Monsieur Dupontel,
a-t-il un philosophe ou une philosophie
qu'il tient à cœur ?
Euh, il y en a un, je lis régulièrement,
c'est Nietzsche par-delà le bien et le
mal. Et puis il y a une phrase qui va
vraiment que que j'ai cultivé il y a
plusieurs décennies, c'est le l'instinct
de défense contre le monde extérieur
porte un nom, ça s'appelle le goût. Et
ça, je m'en suis beaucoup servi quand
j'étais justement en rupture d'étude.
Même dans les choix des films, il y a
des films qui me plaisaient beaucoup et
c'était pas forcément le goût de mes
copains. Donc, on avait des des
discussions en diablé par rapport à ça.
Et donc, voilà, cette phrase Nietzsche,
mais j'en connais d'autres, mais c'est
celui-là. Spinoza, j'ai jamais compris.
J'essaie régulièrement de me remettre à
l'éthique, mais j'ai jamais compris. euh
Montagne euh vive apprendre à mourir. Il
y a une édition d'ailleurs qui est
sortie récemment où ils ont enfin
vulgarisé un peu dans un français
moderne les essais de montagne. Je vous
recommande, elle est vraiment très
chouette. Euh voilà. Euh et puis il y a
une biographie de de montaigne de par
Sarah Blackwell qui est extraordinaire.
Et c'est intéressant dans dans mon
thème, c'est qu'on cette cette biographe
qui est américaine, beaucoup
d'Américains parlent très bien de la
culture française. J'ai vu il y a pas
longtemps une biographie de Zola aussi
qui était poustouflante. Et Sarah
Blackwell dit que Montagne a eu une NDE,
c'estàd qu'il il a fait une near de
experience et donc c'est ça qui fait
qu'il se serait mis dans sa d'Ivoire,
qu'il aurait commencé à réfléchir.
Voilà, c'est très intéressant. Très
intéressant l'anecdote scénaristique
pour justifier cette pensée profonde.
Question internet, que penses-t-il
d'Alexandre Astier ?
Je sais qui c'est mais j'ai honte, je
connais pas très bien son travail mais
je sais qui c'est.
Est-il vous est-ce que vous êtes
légaliste ?
Tant que la loi me respecte, oui, mais
quand elle commence à être fait par des
gens qui respectent plus vraiment
l'individu, je trouve que la désobance
civile qui est évoquée est tout à fait
légitime. Voilà, tant que ça se passe
doucement.
Question internet, c'est possible.
Quel est son plus grand regret ?
Mon plus grand regret euh
mon plus grand regret euh
j'aime pas trop les cultiver les regrets
mais quelque part ils s'imposent.
J'aurais aimé être confronté euh à la
dimension de la culture plutôt dans ma
vie. Voilà, je sortais de d'un milieu de
parents vraiment aimants. Mon père
sortait d'un milieu très rustique. Donc
c'était mon héros parce que moi j'ai
bénéficié de l'ascenseur social. Il
était médecin mais il sortait du d'une
petite ferme des côtes d'armoire très
très modestes qu'on a toujours
d'ailleurs dans la famille. Et donc ils
m'ont vraiment éduqué mais ils m'ont
éduqué comme dans les 30 glorieuses on
éduquait les gamins. C'està dire que le
matérialisme était était un
aboutissement. Et j'ai raté beaucoup de
cultures des années 70 quand j'étais
mom. J'ai raté notamment bah les les
mises en scène de Mouchkin dans sa
grande période. J'aurais aimé connaître
ça et j'ai été j'ai pas été éduqué vers
ça. J'ai été éduqué vers au théâtre ce
soir parce que je ne regrette pas. Mais
j'aurais aimé avoir une autre une autre
partition culturelle, musicale
philosophique et et surtout théâtral et
et au cinéma. Bon au cinéma j'étais
gâté, il y avait Belmondo, il y a de
funesse. Donc voilà, on pouvait déjà
voir ça avec les parents, c'était super.
Mais il y a tout un cinéma que j'ai pas
eu accès. J'ai eu accès après parce que
j'ai pu revoir les films, on peut les
revoir le théâtre par exemple de Mkin,
j'ai pas pu le revoir quand j'étais mom
et je le regrette. Voilà. culturel,
c'est ça.
Vous avez vu un film qui s'appelle
American History X.
Oui, bien sûr. Ou ou bah, la performance
de l'acteur est extraordinaire,
mais c'est un des aspects de la culture
américaine, des viandes ultra viiolentes
et tout. C'est l'apparition du grand
Norton qui est intéressant et c'est un
film, je rappelle plus le nom du méteur
en scène. Enfin bref, j'ai vu ce film et
voilà, c'est terrifiant, terrifiant de
violence et terrifiant de déviance.
Vous verrez, est-ce que vous voyez faire
un film du même genre en France ?
Moi, je peux faire que des films qui
m'inspirent. Euh pour ça, d'ailleurs, je
suis un auteur limité redondant. Je dis
sans sans fausse modestie, c'est vrai
dès qu'il y a des histoires de
filiation, d'éducation et tout,
d'enfance, ça me touche beaucoup et
quelque part le film même sur la
politique dont je vous ai parlé que
j'essaie d'ébaucher de faire, je trouve
les motivations du héros en plongeant
dans son enfance. Je lui invente un un
passé tragique et qui fait qu'il est
motivé par rapport à ses actes. Voilà.
Euh alors, faire American ça me parle
pas. Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ? Il
y a eu des films violent. J'ai participé
en tant qu'acteur à un film que je
considère comme un cheov. C'est c'est
irréversible. C'est fait par un poète
noir magnifique et Gaspard Noé. Donc je
peux pas le faire. J'ai une approche
totalement différente de de ce qu'il
raconte, mais il participait en tant
qu'acteur et je l'ai fait avec le plus
d'enthousiasme possible, même si des
fois c'était objectivement difficile.
Que pensent-ils des humoristes actuels ?
Ben, je les connais pas beaucoup, je
commence à être vieux, j'ai pas de télé.
De temps en temps, je vais sur internet.
Alors si si, j'ai j'ai une j'ai une une
quasi vénération pour les mecs du
Palmachot. J'adore Grégoire Ludig et
puis David Marseille qui d'ailleurs sont
venus faire un petit coucou dans le
film. J'espère les voir dans les
prochains plus longuement. et Kenjy qui
est un mec extrêmement lucide et très
intéressant. Donc je les connais,
j'exagère quand j'y connais pas mais il
y en a plein d'autres mais que comme
j'ai pas la télé voilà je les connais
pas forcément mais je dit j'ai vu ces
spectacles, je trouve ça très
intéressant.
Alors là il y a c'est c'est une question
mais c'est pas une question je vais
essayer de la délayer un peu. C'est
Albert président pourinterrogation ou
point d'exclamation.
Des fois je me dis que ça pourrait pas
être pire. Alors j'ai pas la compétence
indiscutablement pour ça. J'ai j'ai pas
la compétence pour ça.
Vous allez soutenir un parti.
Je peux pas. C'est une façon encore une
fois de faire la politique que je ne
comprends pas. Le militantisme est
quelque chose est à la politique que
l'intégrisme est à la religion. C'est
complètement con. C'est radicaux. C'est
c'est des c'est des radicaux absolus de
de voir ces gens dans dans les meeting.
Ah d'ailleurs, je vais commencer le
prochain. J'ai déjà les images en train
d'hurler Nicolas Nicolas ou je sais pas
qui complètement con. Euh voilà. En plus
ces valeurs droite gauche sont des
valeurs qui objectivement ont disparu
avec la chute de de l'empire soviétique.
Donc faut réinventer d'autres valeurs et
l'écologie devrait être au centre de
tout. et tous ces gens brillants,
intelligents, cultivés qui ont eu la
chance en plus de faire des études pour
soi-disant nous gouverner devrait se
regrouper plutôt de s'engueuler à
l'Assemblée nationale, il y aurait des
solutions. L'intelligence, elle est là
mais elle veut pas s'exprimer ou elle
s'exprime mal. Les égos sont au su de
l'intelligence, c'est le drame de la
politique française. Pour que quelqu'un
d'intelligence s'exprime, il faut déjà
qu'il ait un ego en retenu et c'est
assez compliqué.
Donc Albert président, j'ai déjà du mal
à gérer mon petit monde mais mais des
fois je suis surpris de de de leur
interprétation, de leur façon de faire.
Je ne comprends pas. C'est comme si le
bon sens était complètement absent de la
réflexion. Donc pourquoi pas après tout
vous avez lu le rapport du GC ?
Ah bah j'arrive plus à lire ces trucs
là, c'est catastrophique. Ça me faut
peur mais peur j'ai des enfants. Moi
dans 20 ans je serai plus là mais ils
seront jeunes encore. Donc il y a pas
que ça. Il y a il y a votre votre
intervenant Girot, j'ai vu son
documentaire, il y a Jean Covici qui qui
est extrêmement brillant. Alors Jean
Covici propose des solutions, il est pas
forcément entendu mais il propose des
solutions. Je dira aussi d'ailleurs dans
dans dans l'isolation thermique et
cetera et cetera mais le G c'est
terrifiant la banquise qu'il font et
mais ça j'entend parler depuis 40 ans.
Pourquoi rien ne se fait ? Je comprends
pas. On a on a des communiquants mais on
a pas des gens qui agissent au pouvoir.
C'est ça qui est flippant.
Ça fout les jetons hein.
Ah bah oui, ça fait 1h et3 que je suis
paniqué devant vous.
Franchement, ils sont au courant de tout
ça ou pas ?
Bah ouais, enfin il y en a il y a le
Oui, oui, le grand là qui a 23 ans, il
le sait. C'est un go vraiment brillant
euh qui est très sensible dans un monde
de brut. Il est sensible, il a du mal à
se positionner, il s'intéresse beaucoup
et il a fait deux masters d'histoire
antique à Londres. Je suis très fier de
lui dans le dernier Kings Collège et
puis j'ai un tout petit. Alors lui tout
petit, il arrive vraiment en plein dans
la bataille. Alors lui l'écologiste très
important, les ordures, le tri des
ordures, il le fait instinctivement.
L'école encore une fois c'est une école
alternative. Voilà, il a déjà ces
précepts là que je trouve vraiment
vraiment intéressant. Maintenant, c'est
pas parce qu'ils sont là que qu'ils vont
changer les choses, c'est des gens qui
sont au dessus qui vont décider de
l'avenir, quoi. Et c'est dommage que
Macron a pas fait les écoles
alternatives.
Il peut-être plus ouverture d'esprit.
Ouais, il
mais il para que son son ministre de
l'éducation Blanqu est féru de ce genre
d'éducation mais c'est l'occasion de
proposer justement aux gens qui veulent
être instituteur deun autre façon
d'enseigner. Je suis sûr que ça
changerait très rapidement les choses.
La génération qui arriverait serait très
différente.
Question d'internet. Que pense monsieur
Dupontel des Césars et du festival de
Cann ? C'est un mal nécessaire. Voilà,
je trouve que c'est je trouve ça bien
parce que ça parle de cinéma et parler
cinéma c'est quelque chose de chouette
indiscutablement. D'ici à participer,
moi ça me met dans un dans un chisme
intérieur assez profond. être artiste ou
essayer de l'être, ce qui est mon cas,
c'est vouloir élever son niveau de
conscience en toute prétention et je
parle pas de bien loin. Donc vous me
pardonnerez cette cette métaphore et
donc du coup vouloir dire je suis le
meilleur en terme de goût, je trouve ça
insolent par rapport justement à au
genre humain. On préempre notre goût, on
préempre nos notre personnalité très tôt
de l'école et c'est pas pour plus tard
vous dire "ça c'est le meilleur film, ça
c'est le meilleur acteur". C'est une
question de goût. Le meilleur bah c'est
le film que vous avez aimé. Le meilleur
vin, c'est le film que c'est le vin que
vous avez bu. C'est ce que vous avez
aimé. Voilà. Voilà l'instinct de défense
quand on mon extérieur porte un
s'appelle le goût. Laissons au moins les
gens avoir du goût. Et je trouve des
fois quand je suis dans cette
positionlà, je me sens gêné par rapport
à ça. Je dis merci aux gens de
reconnaître le travail qui a été fourni
mais en tant qu'intervenant là je suis
dans un vrai une vraie panique
intérieure par rapport à ça. Mais entre
cracher dans la soupe et se rouler
dedans, il y a une nuance, c'est le bord
de l'assiette. Donc j'essaie de faire le
tour mais voilà mais voilà can c'est un
dernier endroit culturel où on peut
parler du cinéma français dans le monde
entier. Ça c'est bien. Les quelques fois
j'y suis allé, j'étais pas super à
l'aise sur le tapis rouge. Une fois je
voulais pas y aller mais c'était pour
irréversible et Gaspar m'a dit "Si tu
vas pas c'est que tuassumes pas le
film." Alors bon, je pouvais pas ne pas
y aller. Et l'autre fois j'y suis allé,
c'était pour le film de Gustave et de
Benoît. Voilà, j'ai beaucoup aimé faire,
c'est le grand soir avec Paul W et on
s'amusait comme des petits fous parce
qu'on prenait la chose à distance. Quant
au César, voilà, je trouve ça bien que
ça existe mais c'est compliqué pour moi
d'y participer. Par exemple, Berny était
nommé au César meilleur premier film,
c'est paradoxal de faire Berny qui est
vraiment une protestation faite avec les
moyens du bord et après d'aller chercher
une récompense. Donc mai, c'était de
l'avoir et à l'époque ça se savait
manifestement. Donc Alain de Greff m'a
appelé quelques jours avant, il me dit
"Rassure-toi, tu l'as pas." C'est pour
vous dire mais en même temps, je trouve
ça bien que ça existe et puis ça
récompense souvent des gens qui ont
beaucoup de talent mais moi, j'ai une
approche qui est différente du truc et
si on peut tolérer cette attitude là, je
les en remercie. Voilà, vous avez alors
euh on va je poserai cette question
après. Quand quand je vous entends
parler, vous utilisez tout le temps des
proverbes ou des phrases de grands
auteurs. Est-ce que c'est votre façon de
comment comment formuler ça ? Est-ce que
c'est votre façon de d'encadrer votre
cerveau, d'encadrer votre pensée,
d'encadrer
Ouais. Ouais. Je suis un mec assez
confus, je l'assume et donc des fois je
trouve une formule qui résume bien cette
confusion mentale dont je la sors. Mais
aussi une phrase somat Mogam qui dit que
les gens qui parlent à coup de coup de
citation c'est des gens pas très
intelligents. Donc je me je me méfie de
cette formulation mais c'est vrai c'est
une façon assez condensée de
raclairement quelque chose qui est assez
confu dans ma tête. Voilà.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé du film
Fight Club ?
Ah je trouve ça je trouve ça je trouve
ça super ce film. Voilà je trouvais ça
super. Bon, il y a un grand formaliste
he David Fincher. Encore une fois, on
retrouve l'excellent Edward Norton et et
puis c'est tiré ah le nom de l'auteur
don j'ai lu tous les bouquins m'échapp
euh l'auteur du livre, excusez-moi, de F
Club, quelqu'un de la voilà.
Oui, Chuck Palanuk. Voilà. Donc j'avais
lu également les autres les autres
ouvrages et non, j'ai trouvé le film
formidable. Le le le le concept est
invraisemblable. Raconte beaucoup de
choses sur encore une fois le monde
qu'on est en train de traverser et j'ai
adoré ce film. J'ai vu plusieurs fois
d'ailleurs puisque formellement en plus
c'est très intéressant grands acteurs,
grands metteurs en scène, grand propos.
Je sais que ça pas été un succès, c'est
dommage parce que il mérite d'être vu et
revu ce film et le coup de la
schizophrénie là, j'ai été bluffé par
rapport à ça, je l'ai pas vu venir.
Voilà, je cherchais comment il allait
s'en sortir mais j'ai été bluffé. Mais
ça c'est Chuck Palek hein, c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas les scénaristes.
Autre question internet, un commentaire
sur Didy Raou.
Didier Raou ?
Alors moi j'ai quand j'étais en
médecine, j'étais j'étais avec deux
copains, voilà, deux copains qui eux ont
eu le courage de continuer. On a préparé
le concours ensemble, on a beaucoup
travaillé. Al il y en a un qui est
devenu un chirurgien obstétrique et puis
l'autre qui est devenu un grand
professeur de grand professeur dans le
sud-est de d'infectexiologie. Voilà.
Donc pendant le Covid, j'étais vraiment
au courant au jour le jour de de ce qui
se passait. Donc donc Raou voilà,
certainement quelqu'un de compétent.
Quand les gens sont trop dans la
lumière, ils me font un peu peur. Voilà,
tout ce que je peux dire. C'est tout ce
que je peux dire. Voilà, il fait un peu
peur des fois. J'ai l'impression qu' il
y a des gens qui aiment bien la lumière.
Ils sont un peu effrayants ces gens-là.
Voilà. Mais je pense c'est quelqu'un de
très compétent en même temps.
Avant de terminer votre carrière, c'est
une question internet. Est-ce que vous
avez quelque chose que vous vous
souhaitez mettre en image ? Est-ce que
vous avez vraiment un
J'aimerais faire un film en étant
débarrassé de la scolarité de la
narration en toute prétention. Pour moi,
la poésie au cinéma, c'est des questions
qui qui ont pas besoin de réponse. Ça
c'est pour moi l'art suprême dans dans
cette forme filmique. Alors les grands
référents, bah c'est c'est 8 et demi de
Fini, c'est c'est Milon Drive de Lynch,
c'est c'est Buffet Froid de Bliz. Voilà,
tout d'un coup par des images, par des
dialogues, par des sons, par de la
musique, on va vous raconter quelque
chose. Récemment la grande desbedza de
Sentido, je trouve ça magnifique. Le
propos est très tenu. Il arrive à faire
une œuvre absolument captivante. Voilà,
donc je sais pas si j'ai les moyens de
ça. J'espère vivre assez longtemps pour
don un coup oser ça et penser que j'en
ai les moyens intellectuels de raconter
une captation de l'extérieur de cette
façonlà. Pour moi, c'est la forme
suprême du cinéma. C'est la forme
poétique. Voilà. En parlant de cinéma là
c'est pas une question mais c'est on va
lire quand même. Euh Cassette son pseudo
il dit "Je rêve depuis toujours de
bosser avec du pontel, j'ai étudié le
ciné, tu veux bien m'aider ? Point
d'interrogation, merci à l'équipe pour
votre boulot. Comment on fait pour
travailler avec vous ?
Oh bah c'est très simple, chaque fois
qu'il y a un film qui se prépare, il y a
une production à des CB films et puis on
fait acte de candidature. En sancien les
acteurs, je reçois énormément de gens.
Je vois tout le monde, je filme tout le
monde parce qu'au-delà de de ce que je
recherche, je suis très intéressé par
les acteurs. J'aime beaucoup cette
tentative humaine d'expression. Je
comprends tellement le mécanisme qui
amène les gens à vouloir jouer, la
comédie que forcément, je suis très
intéressé. Et c'est grâce à ça,
d'ailleurs, j'ai rencontré Bastien
Hugetto en casting après avoir fait
plein de tutos, une série d'essais. Donc
voilà, c'est c'est relativement simple.
quand il y aura un prochain projet,
j'espère d'ici 2 ans, on se mettra en
quête d'acteurs, on se mettra en quête
de techniciens et donc en général, bon
le technicien, j'ai vraiment un réseau
très très abouti et de gens que avec qui
je souhaite travailler, même s'ils sont
pas disponibles, j'attends qu'ils soient
disponibles. Cadreur, machinerie,
lumière, VFX, c'est très important ces
gensl sont très très importants pour
moi. Et par contre les acteurs là dès
qu'on sera en route, surtout qu'ils
hésitent pas à venir et puis on les
filmera, on les verra et cetera sans
aucun problème.
Question internet Albert Dupontel, que
pensez-vous de la place de la femme dans
la société, des luttes féministes ? du
cinéma féministe, Baise-moi de Virginie
des Pente et son essai King Kong
Théorie.
Euh la place de les femmes dans la
société,
je la trouve
indispensable. Voilà, je trouve les
femmes infiniment plus intelligentes que
les mecs. Nous, on est un peu encombré
par la testostérone, les femmes beaucoup
moins. Et dans l'histoire de l'humanité,
il faut reconnaître quand même qu'il y a
eu a des grandes intervenantes Catherine
de Russie, il y a eu Marie Stuire, il y
a eu Élisabeth d'Angleterre, je parle
Ellisabethant à l'époque de de
Shakespeare. Voilà donc pas dire
qu'elles étaient oubliées. Par contre,
c'est toujours ce créé crétin de
l'individu du mal qui veut asseoir sa
dominance et elles ont parfaitement
raison de de dire qu'elles existent.
Mais c'est même pas besoin de le dire à
travers ces mouvements-là. Moi, j'ai
parfaitement perçu l'utilité,
l'indispensabilité euh au-delà de ma
mère qui m'a fait de de la relation avec
la femme que je trouve considère
objectivement, intellectuellement très
supérieur. Euh je fréquente beaucoup de
femmes dans mon travail à commencer par
ma productrice. Toute l'équipe
dirigeante quand je travaille, c'est que
des femmes et je suis surpris des fois
de choses que je ne vois pas et que ces
dames voient. Et puis c'est par hasard
si je vais chercher des grandes actrices
pour travailler, elles expriment une
virilité que je suis bien incapable
d'exprimer moi-même et c'est infiniment
plus nuancé, infiniment plus euh
raconté, clair et notamment bah dans
Adieu les con les émotions de Virginie
qui peut me rendre ça à part justement
une jolie femme qui plusait une grande
actrice, vous voyez ce que je veux dire
? Donc j'ai même pas cette question se
pose même pas. Voyez, c'est c'est comme
bienement en parlant il y a pas
longtemps avec un un chauffeur VTC, il
parlait de racisme et je me rends compte
que moi quand j'étais mom, j'ai pas
connu le racisme. On était j'étais dans
un C de banlieu à CS Montagne à
Confonorine et je me rappelle de la
diversité culturelle déjà de l'époque
des années 70, il y avait des portugais,
des espagnols, il y avait déjà des des
nordfricains et tout et j'ai pas du tout
ce sentiment de de enfin vraiment on
avait des rapports très très faciles et
depuis quelques décennies, j'ai vraiment
l'impression que ça s'est cristallisé.
Effectivement voilà la culture disparaît
et et tout d'un coup bah il y a un repli
sur soi et les identités ressortent dans
le mauvais sens du terme. Et voilà le
racisme voilà c'est en parlant avec ce
ce jeune mec qui me racontait ses
déboirs justement en tant que musulman
et je me rendais compte que j'ai pas
connu ça. J'ai pas connu ce rapport à
l'autre quand j'étais quand j'étais
enfant. Voilà ferme ma parenthèse.
Question internet. Elliot Musk doit-on
l'arrêter ? Alors, je vais délayuer sa
question, c'est est-ce que la société
que Elion Musk est en train de nous
promettre de nos cerveaux connectés, des
voitures connectées, des tout connectés,
est-ce que ça ça vous fait peur ?
Bah tout ce qu' tout dépend de ce qu'on
fait du progrès. Elan Musk c'est un
génie objectivement quand il fait des
voitures électriques. Moi j'ai une
voiture électrique par exemple. Voyez,
bon ben je trouve ça pratique, j'ai pas
une Tesla, j'ai une petite Hyundai
que que je loue à l'année. Enfin bref et
donc voilà. Alors, je sais que faire une
voiture électrique, ça c'est c'est
beaucoup plus polluant une fois et demi
qu'une voiture énergie enfin moteur
thermique. Bon voilà, faudra peut-être
résoudre ce problème là. Par contre, je
diffuse un peu moins de CO2 quand je
roule. Donc ces mecs-là sont des génies.
Le progrès qu'ils amènent, bah c'est
intéressant. Maintenant, qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ce progrès ? Quand c'est la hypers
surveillance que vous évoquez, bah c'est
très choquant. Aller sur Mars, est-ce
que c'est utile de dépenser tous ces
milliards quand on voit à quel point la
planète en a besoin ? Je reprends un
vieux crédau. Que faire de ce génie ?
C'est un génie fou. Il est l'incarnation
typique de l'Amérique que j'évoquais
dans les années 20 qui est devenue
folle. Il incarne ça. La la culture
américaine, c'est une culture juvénile,
dynamique, mais totalement
irresponsable. Donc, il faut la juguler.
C'est pas avec les leaders qui arrivent
là que qui vont être jugulés. Je sais
pas ce qu'on Elon Musk, c'était
quelqu'un qui a d'immense qualité. Oui,
le monde qui propose à partir du moment
où il est à ce point-là égoïste, il est
dangereux. Maintenant, quand si vraiment
on arrive à avoir de la circuler en
polluant moins et à voyager en étant
moins énergivore, c'est intéressant
aussi. Je sais pas comment manier un un
tel créateur quoi. Il est à fois il est
à fois fascinant et inquiétant.
Est-ce que vous avez vu le film
Existence ?
Non, j'ai pas vu celui-là. C'est un film
de Crenonber, c'est ça ? Ouais, mais je
l'ai pas vu celui-là.
Euh, on va reprendre une question
internet.
Euh,
puis-je regarder son ça ? Non, ça on va
pas spoiler le film. Non,
ce serait dommage quand même.
Donc le roi et l'oiseau en a parlé. On
va descendre trois pages. Attention, on
va en prendre une.
Stan les cubric.
Ouais. Y a-t-il un long métrage qu'il a
en particulièrement marqué dans sa
filmographie ?
Docteur Strange Love ? Voilà,
performance hallucinante de Peter
Sellers qui va jusqu'à interpréter trois
personnages et c'est la farce
d'ailleurs. C'est la seule farce, la
seule comédie même si elle est vraiment
sur un fond désespéré déjà euh c'est la
seule vraie comédie de Stan Cubric avec
également Lolita. Je trouve magnifique
ce qui ce qu'il a fait la la gamine
s'appelle Sou Lions et puis et puis
voilà je voilà c'est les deux films
vraiment que j'ai jamais compris de
Béner l'espace et j'ai souvent eu un
complexe de ça et en parlant avec Tergil
m'a dit que lui non plus n'avait jamais
compris ce film alors du coup je me
sentais rassuré et mais c'est pas exclu
je le vois régulièrement ce film mais
voilà Lolita et Strange Love c'est
vraiment des des films magnifiques voilà
qui m'ont qui m'ont beaucoup touché
question internet que pensent-il dans
arrêtez de balancer les questions tout
d'un coup parce que sinon je perds la
ligne. Merci. Que pensent-t-il des
actions militantes violentes et directes
?
Dès qu'on passe par la violence, on se
trompe, on se diabolise, on se fout dans
l'erreur. Maintenant, je peux comprendre
l'envie de violence tellement le système
peut être répressif.
Euh voilà, c'est pas une façon de faire.
Le enf je dire le le fond est
certainement cohérent. La forme l'
beaucoup moins. Euh l'expression
violente, c'est déjà se mettre dans son
tort. Et même si on a raison, quand on
s'exprime violemment, on se met dans son
tort. Et je sais de quoi je parle. Quand
je me bagarrais à l'école, des fois
j'avais raison mais à l'arrivée, j'avais
tort puisque j'avais perdu mon sang
frroid. Donc combattre un système,
d'ailleurs, c'est un peu des thèmes du
film que je voudrais faire par la suite.
Combattre un système, c'est à mon avis
beaucoup avoir l'apparence du système.
Et mon héros dans le prochain film
encore une fois qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas écrit, il dit "Robert Kennedy avait
raison mais la seule erreur qu'il a fait
c'est qu'il l'a dit." Voilà, il faut pas
le dire. Voilà. Donc mon héros avant
caché, camouflé. C'est ce que j'aimerais
raconter dans la prochaine dystopie.
Donc voilà, la violence peut être
comment dire fondée mais à l'arrivée est
forcément illégitime.
La violence et la force des faibles et
commence où s'arrête les connaissances.
Exactement. Je sais pas qui a dit ça
mais c'est très fondé. Voilà.
Euh question internet. Aimerait-il
réaliser une série télé en plusieurs
saisons ? Un showrunner ?
Alors showrunner non. Une série télé
pourquoi pas ? faudra encore retrouver
le sujet et je vous cache pas que des
fois j'y songe parce que je trouve des
trucs vraiment intéressants qui il y en
a une que j'ai vu il y a pas longtemps
qui s'appelle Babylone Berlin et qui est
une série allemande et qui est très très
bien produite formellement très bien
faite. C'est un mteur enseignement qui a
fait également Cloud Atlas, un film aux
États-Unis produit par les frères
Vakovski, les sœurs Vakowski maintenant
qui est un film très très intéressant,
Claud Atlas magnifique et tout. Donc il
y a un grand formaliste et la série télé
raconte la monté du nazisme dans les
années 20 et cette série m'a beaucoup
intéressé. Saison 1 surtout 2 et 3 un
peu moins bien mais saison 1 vraiment
formidable. Il y a il y a il y a un jeu
quasi sensuel de lumière, de caméras. Il
y a des grands acteurs, il y a une
histoire qui qui est pas inintéressante
et puis c'est la preuve que l'Europe
peut faire des des séries télé du niveau
d'Hollywood et c'est vraiment ce que
l'Europe devrait faire aujourd'hui. La
seule façon pour l'Europe d'exister,
c'est de retrouver une entité et la
seule façon de retrouver une identité,
c'est la culture. Il devrait y avoir 10
gros films européens euh chaque année
euh produit par les Français, les
Anglais, les Allemands et cetera. C'est
encore une fois, je ne comprends pas que
l'Europe, les leaders européens ne
sous-estiment complètement la force de
la culture. Voilà.
Après, a-t-il vu film tourné par
DiCaprio avant le déluge ? Et qu'en
pensent-il ? Je trouve que c'est con de
parler de la pollution des tours
d'hélicoptère su de la banquise.
C'est ça qui m'a choqué sur le film.
Bon, je sais pas là, je sais pas. Là,
c'est une star d'ollywood. Je pense
qu'elle il a un impact très fort sur les
gens bien évidemment. Euh mais la façon
dont il s'exprime, elle est pas elle est
pas très malicieuse. Voilà, c'est pas
très malin parce qu'effectivement, il
fait des tours dédicaux sur la banquise
et cetera et cetera. Euh
je sais pas, je pense qu'il devrait
donner la parole à des gens. Voilà, il
devrait produire pour des gens
compétents puissent en parler de façon
plus h, plus réservé, plus cultivé, même
si le personnage est hautement
respectable et c'est un grand acteur.
Voilà, donc c'est le seul bémol que j'ai
eu quand j'ai vu quand j'ai vu ce
documentaire.
Luc Besson, vous voulez dire un mot sur
Luc Besson, la cité du cinéma et tout ça
?
Luc Besson, c'est c'est quelqu'un
quelqu'un qui a marqué l'histoire du
cinéma français indignablement. Après le
baisson que moi j'ai aimé des années 90,
je regardais ses mouvements de caméra,
c'est quelqu'un qui aime beaucoup le 18
mm par exemple, voyez, un peu comme
toute proportion gardée, un peu comme
Oron West qui est un des un des fans de
cette focale là. Donc je me rappelle
avoir vu Nikita voilà regarder comment
il faisait il y avait il y avait un
plaisir de fummer, il y avait une
jubilation, il y avait une sensualité
qui avec le temps a disparu. C'est c'est
devenu un grand homme d'affair quelque
part et et donc j'ai un peu perdu la
piste proprioceptive avec ce personnage
là mais c'est un gars indiscutablement
qui qui a marqué le sino et notamment
quand j'évoquais le le fait de quitter
la Hongrie pour avoir la de revenir en
France, je sais que c'est lui qui a fait
des démarches pour son film Valérian.
Enfin, il a quand même réussi à obtenir
ce que la loi sur le crédit d'impôt qui
était limité au films de 7 millions
d'euros puisse aller sur des films plus
gros. Et grâce à ça, ben on a
repositionné le clim en France et on a
fait marcher la fameuse économie
française. Donc voilà, c'est quelqu'un
qui a qui a marqué le cinéma français.
Question internet. Que penses-t-il de
Julien Assange ? Vous savez, en ce
moment, il y a son procès.
Ouais. Alors, il se trouve que je
connais bien son avocat,
Antoine Vet qui est un mec assez
fascinant et alors je connais pas assez
si vous voulez l'informatique et tout.
Euh, il est clair que s'il est extradé,
c'est une catastrophe.
sa démarche citoyenne, je la trouve
fondée. Le personnage, j'arrive pas à le
cerner. Voilà, j'arrive pas à le cerner.
Mais
on nous cache tout, on nous dit rien et
c'est bien qu'il y a des gens qui de
temps en temps nous disent ce qui se
passe vraiment. Après, quand il raconte
notamment cette vidéo là sur les
cach pas tout hein, 98 % de la formation
est dans le domaine public.
Oui. Alors, faut-il encore la trouver
quoi. Mais c'est ce qu' a pris, c'est ce
qui ach Ouais. ou la chercher. J'ai vu
cette vidéo terrible où les gars sont en
train de tirer sur des irakiens qui sont
en train de Voilà. Bon, j'ai je me je me
doute bien que que faire la guerre,
c'est ça. Lui, il prouve que c'est
effectivement faire la guerre, c'est
c'est ça et c'est une façon de
communiquer avec les gens très
importante. Voilà. Alors après
l'histoire personnelle, je la connais
pas trop. Il y a tellement de de choses
qui sont le personnage a tellement été
diabolisé, j'arrive pas à rencerner le
vrai. Toujours est-il que c'est sûr que
je trouve qu'il aurait dû retrouver
refuge en France, indiscutablement.
C'est vraiment le pays où il aurait dû
trouver refuge, mais là ça nous dépasse
complètement. Les intérêts
franco-américains se sont opposés à
cette cette extradition. C'est peut-être
pas les intérêts, c'est notre notre
simple capacité à pouvoir le protéger.
C'était sous qui c'était sous Hollande
que ça s'est pos la question s'est
posée. C'est ça ?
Oui. Oui. Sous Hollande mais
vous protégeez physiquement, vous pensez
qu'ils auraient été pas capable de Ah
oui, carrément, il en danger de mort à
ce point-là.
On est incapable de protéger n'importe
qui sur notre territoire français. He
clair. Ça c'est clair. Ouais. Mais je
pensais au moins qu'il pouvait qu'il
pouvait être extradé en France. Ça
aurait donné un sens justement à
l'identité culturelle française. Après,
je sais qu'il est en Angleterre dans des
conditions assez sévères de détention et
qu'il y a une bagarre pour éviter
l'extradition qui sera en ce qui lui
concerne définitif parce qu'une fois
qu'il sera là-bas, il pourra plus
revenir. Je comprends pas la démarche
d'Obama d'avoir ostracisé ce personnage
là. Snowden est très intéressant. Il y a
un documentaire aussi que j'ai vu qui
est vraiment intéressant. J'ai lu son
bouquin et je vois la conscience
citoyenne du personnage qui est un fou
de la Constitution américaine et tout
d'un coup qui se dit "Mais c'est
n'importe quoi ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire et heureusement qu'il est allé
se planquer." Je crois qu'il était en
Russie. Mais là aussi la France devrait
l'accueillir. C'est encore une fois il
faut prendre ce ce leadership culturel,
ce leadership identitaire d'expression,
de liberté d'expression. Quelle que soit
les relations européenne, aux alentours
et américaine. La France devrait
retrouver le siècle des lumières
justement devrait se faire maintenant.
On devrait accueillir un S, on devrait
accueillir Snowden. Pas forcément leur
donner raison mais au moins les
accueillir pour pouvoir leur donner un
temps de repos, un temps de réflexion,
un fameux moratoire avant qu'il soient
jugés par des instances internationales.
J'arrive pas à comprendre le rôle
français par rapport à ça.
C'est très simple à comprendre, très
simple. Pas de couille, pas
d'embrouille.
Ben ouais ben c'est dommage parce que
moi les leaders dont je parlais
Clémanceau et de goal quand j'ai regardé
l'histoire de France c'est vraiment les
deux leaders qui sortent très forts.
Clémanu personnage très intéressant
ambigu il a fait tirer sur les grévistes
mais très intéressant il a prévenu les
les communards du carnage qui allait se
passer médecin à l'origine celui qui a
quand même accueilli le le Zola pour son
pour son Jacus et au départ il est
convaincu de la codité de Drefus faut le
savoir. Et c'est Zola qui dit mais le
procès a pas été bien fait à dire si ça
pas été bien fait à ce moment-là OK on
met on publie et après il a été
convaincu l'innocence de Drefus. Très
intéressant. Voilà, donc ces deux
leaders avaient ce que vous
appeleziquement des couilles et donc
voilà. Voilà. Effectivement
effectivement effectivement mais le le
système qui appelle ces gens au pouvoir
qui appelle ces gens ces grands
narcistes dans la lumière du pouvoir
appelle pas des gens qu'on écoute
justement. Voilà, c'est peut-être ça le
l'origine du problème.
Des overs
ou des overs ? Ouais, c'est peut-être
des overs qu'il faudrait justement je
sais pas qui on pourrait avoir dire
compliqué hein.
Ouais.
Trump un mot sur Trump. Bah Trump c'est
c'est une des déviances une des
déviances de la culture américaine.
Alors c'est drôle parce que les
Américains mettent toujours leur
constitution en avant. Alors faut savoir
que la constitution américaine elle a
été faite par des des quincajanaires
riches blancs et dont certains étaient
esclavagistes. Donc faut pas non plus
sans arrêt brandir la constitution comme
une vérité. Ils ont la même constitution
depuis 200 ans. Nous il y a 200 ans, on
était encore sous l'aristocratie.
Donc quelque part il y a quelque chose
qui va pas. Et quand on réfléchit
d'ailleurs au fait que Trump arrive, bah
c'est justement cette constitution qui
n'a jamais été changée. Quand ils ont
fait les grands électeurs, l'Amérique ne
possédait qu'un tiers du territoire et
l'idée c'était donner plus de voix au
fermiers qui avaient 1000 2000 hectares
pour que sa voix soit plus forte que
l'habitant à New York. Et et mais ce
système-là, il est périmé depuis belle
durette. Il se coloniser l'Amérique
entière en massacrant les Indiens et
même coloniser le monde. Et il continue
à garder ce système de vote qui fait
qu'un vote populaire peut être
infériorisé par rapport à fait de grands
électeurs. Donc voilà. Donc c'est à la
fois bah c'est un sociopathe
archifréquent
dans les réseaux enfin dans la
toléréalité américaine. Voilà, c'est un
c'est un multidéviant du capitalisme.
Pourquoi la constitution américaine
est-elle aussi mal faite qu'elle permet
l'ascension au pouvoir d'un individu
comme ça ? Voilà la la parole populaire
aux États-Unis, elle est brimée
indiscutablement et je pense qu'elle
reste primée encore une fois sur les
prochaines élections qui arrivent et et
donc voilà c'est c'est le il incarne la
déviance constitutionnelle de
l'Amérique. Voilà si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi. Voilà.
Question internet que je vais couper un
peu. Monsieur Dupontel a-t-il envisagé
de faire un film d'animation ?
Euh si j'en avais les moyens, avec grand
plaisir, mais je n'ai pas les moyens.
Faut savoir que l'animation c'est un
truc très compliqué. Il y a d'ailleurs
une école en France, l'école des
Gobelins que dont tous les les élèves
sont s'arrache littéralement la sortie
par les les studios Disney. Ils font des
trucs extraordinaires et tout. Donc j'ai
pas les compétences de ça. Mais pourquoi
pas participer à l'élaboration d'un d'un
scénario parce qu'il y a des choses
sublimes qui sont faites dans ce domaine
objectivement.
Est-ce que on arrive à la fin de notre
interview ? On a toujours deux questions
rituelles qui ne sont pas des questions.
Trois livres à conseiller à notre
communauté et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Vous rendez compte l'impression que vous
me mettez ? Alors des livres, je vous
dirai l'éloge de la fuite de la Bori.
Voilà intéressant. La BI est un
comportementaliste chirurgien au départ
et qui un des premiers à avoir trouvé le
la molécule de chloromazine qui est un
tranquillisant. Grâce à ce cette
découverte, il a fait un laboratoire
d'étude du comportement humain. Il a
écrit mouvrages et loge de la fuite est
un est un bouquin euh vraiment très très
intéressant sur le comportement humain
qui regroupe un petit peu tout ce qu'on
a évoqué euh pendant ce petit moment
passé ensemble.
Et euh notamment, il y a un film qui a
été fait via les loges de la fuite,
c'est mon oncle d'Amérique d'Alan René
avec entre autres de par Dieu qui est un
film également très intéressant, moins
que le livre, moins clair mais en tout
cas très intéressant. pour le premier
bouquin. Le deuxè le deuxème
et ben de l'inégalité parmi les sociétés
de Jarry Diamond qui est un parcours de
toute l'origine humaine en fait de la de
la Corne est de l'Afrique pour ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui l'homo homo sapien
c'est arrivé il y a à peu près 300000
ans et a commencé à coloniser toute la
terre repoussant les néandertal et le
Cagnon même si même des fois on se dit
qu'ils sont encore là quand on voit
certains homo homo sapiens et donc c'est
tout le parcours humain par rapport à ça
c'est absolument passionnant on se rend
compte qu'on est tous frères et sœur on
se rend compte que Ève a probablement
existé dans la mesure où il y a une
femme homos Ça fait une femme
néandertalienne qui a une mutation
génétique qui a donné ce fameux cortex
lob frontal qui fait la différence entre
le néandertal et le chromagnon. C'est
l'homos sapiens ça le cerveau de
l'imagination. Voilà tout ça c'est dans
ce bouquin. C'est vraiment très
intéressant. Et puis pour pas être trop
sérieux un livre d'Hugo qui est pas très
connu s'appelle les travers de la mer
qui est extraordinaire. C'est un livre
que alors c'est un livre que j'aimerais
bien adapter mais c'est très cher. C'est
un film d'époque enfin c'est un livre
d'époque. Il raconte la saga d'un d'un
petit pêcheur de guerre qui cherche à
séduire une femme. C'est passionnant.
C'est pas le plus connu mais il est
magnifique. Voilà, il y en a beaucoup
beaucoup d'autres que je avant le
conseil pour les jeunes générations. Là,
on nous demande trois films à
conseiller.
Ah ouais, trois films sera plus
intéressant.
Alors là aussi, il y en a des centaines.
Alors, peut-être les moins connus.
Alors, les moins connus et des choses
assez variées. Euh Beinger de Alashbi
avec Peter Sellers euh tiré d'un livre
dont le nom, un auteur russe le nom
m'échappe qui a écrit l'oiseau de feu.
Peut-être que quelqu'un sur la
communauté pourra le trouver ce nom-là.
Il a un nom compliqué. Jersey quelque
chose Kozinski Jersey Kozinski voilà
c'est un chef che absolu magnifique
magnifique dont je me suis beaucoup
inspiré pour Berny il y a qu'un
personnage qui a un signase qui l'a vu,
c'est Jean-Pierre Jeunet qui a vu que je
m'étais inspiré ce bouquin de très loin
malgré tout. Peter SER sur de son art
qui en plus avait produit ce film. Voilà
pour le premier. Euh
alors un film étonnant étonnant pas très
bien connu. Un condamné à mort s'est
échappé de Bresson. Brisson, c'est assez
difficile. Des fois, j'y suis resté mais
quand j'y suis allé, c'était un
condonment s'est échappé. Ça c'est très
très bien. Dépouillement total de mise
en scène, voix off, acteur amateur et ça
raconte pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale l'évasion d'un condam à mort
d'une prison quelque part à Lyon. Et
moi, c'est des des DVD de Bresson, je
les ai pris des fois parce que je suis
insomnia comme ça je vais bien dormir.
C'était un préjugé débile parce que le
film est passionnant, extraordinaire et
voilà. Et voilà. Faut que ce ce film est
magnifique. Et alors 1 3è un 3è il y en
a tellement tellement bah voilà je je me
répète mais Bril de Terry Guillam vision
prophétique poétique inventive
extraordinaire du monde d'aujourd'hui
qui a été faite il y a 35 ans fondateur
en ce qui me concerne et on peut pas
raconter mieux le monde d'aujourd'hui
que par quelqu'un qui l'a écrit il y a
35 ans. Voilà. Bon il y en a d'autres
encore.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Alors ça les conseillers j'ai envie de
vous dire bonne chance les gars. Moi
j'ai fait mon temps. Euh un conseil
soyez vous-même. Voilà. N'écoutez pas,
n'écoutez pas ce qu'on dit. N'écoutez
pas, ne regardez pas la télé. Euh, allez
sur internet de temps en temps, de temps
en temps pour des chaînes comme la
vôtre. Et puis et puis cultivez-vous
mais pas dans le sens scolaire. Allez
voir les films, allez voir des grands
films, allez voir des grands tableaux,
euh allez voir des œuvres d'art,
regarder la nature à défaut d'y aller
physiquement, regarder tous les grands
documentaires qu'on a pu faire
là-dessus. Il y en a un paquet des
magnifiques. Euh voilà.
C'est compliqué, c'est confus ce que je
dis. Mais soyez vous-même dans tout ça
quoi. C'est très N'écoutez pas N'écoutez
pas trop les adultes. Voilà, ils disent
beaucoup de conneries. Même quand ils
veulent faire du bien, ils disent
beaucoup de conneries. Faites-vous
confiance à vous-même. Voilà. Soyez
vous-même. Voilà. Voilà. Trouvez-vous.
Trouvez-vous. Voilà.
Albert du Pontel. Merci.
Merci à vous. C'est bon. On est dans les
temps. Super.
[Musique]